[Music]
oh hello everybody you know what's
interesting about this coming weekend
it's gonna be a rainy weekend here in
L.A yeah it's a rainy day out here in
Los Angeles that's right today's episode
is sponsored by SeatGeek and manscape to
we love our sponsors don't we uh they
really are the greatest
um we got a heck of a show here lots of
fun
first of all love is catching up we've
forced him to do all of the challenges
that he's missed yeah when he was living
in Sweden now that he's here
he's done a lot of them but one that he
hasn't done is basically the uh ink blot
test of the H3 Studios AKA making a clay
sculpture of my head
it was actually very fun you're done
yeah you're happy with the result uh
yeah I'm pretty happy yeah you think it
says anything about you
um
yeah I mean it's up to the boulder I
guess okay yeah I'm gonna analyze your
whole life from this good and then uh uh
additionally
Ela who is pregnant and who is craving
we have put together weird pregnancy
food combinations amazing for you to try
and tell us what you like I'm sorry
we'll put in our tier list because right
now Everyone likes fearless are you
hungry I'm hungry yes
I've been hungry at all hours all day
what should we do about it it scares me
shouldn't scare you you've got a little
you've got a little human right there
with me because I in my previous
pregnancies I gained a lot of weight 50
pounds but that's normal
it's on the high end from what I
understand I don't know it's fine but
I'm like if I'm starting out already
like this I'm gonna gain like 80 this
time well done no you're not gonna get
80. that's nuts well who cares yeah
so what do you want to eat
anything
okay
um just name it
all right well we'll see I think there's
something all right there's some funky
combos we'll do
um that's basically our main segments
but we got all kinds of good stuff to
talk about
um
[Music]
God I'm so tired I could not I slept so
horribly last night I kept having
it wasn't even a nightmare it was just
really weird reoccurring dream oh
oh that was so weird
you're like you feel like you wake up
and you go back to sleep to the same
time yeah oh it was
hey Gabe yeah you pumping gas people are
asking if you're high yeah I guess I
know what you guys mean but no I'm not
my eyes are real squinty because I'm
tired oh damn look at that slice boy
talk to me about that
it's a fresh pizza it's a fresh pizza
just made
damn that looks good as right Ela
yep we can do something about that
we've got the pepperoni
you said you made it
something like that whoa what like
what's up what is it like
[Applause]
because you're sitting outside a pizza
shop
which is actually very nutritious
freshly made but it's freshly made well
give us a bite don't keep us waiting
tell us how is it you know what I mean
let's let's get it while it's hot
yeah ah there it is oh
that's hot hot
that made me want a pizza
the thing is though when you order pizza
you don't get that yeah
yeah it's different yeah it's different
from making my pizza I order it and they
make it for me okay I see so something
like that I got you how you doing my own
pizza anything fun right anything fun
happening this weekend
okay
you getting ready for the big rainstorm
coming
sure tonight it's a break from the
sunshine that's what I'll say did you
hear about it
it's like a hurricane
yeah it's like a hurricane maybe not a
hurricane but a it's probably
just a rain well no it is literally a
hurricane right now coming up from
Mexico people are boarding up their
windows and
uh no they're not not in La anyway
no but there is a there's a hurricane
coming up and it's going to be like a
tropical storm when it hits
Los Angeles which is a I have a funny uh
anecdote about that we were gonna go
whale watching this weekend oh yeah okay
and we're like oh a hurricane it's like
a once in like never before basically a
hurricane hitting Los Angeles like this
yeah and like we call the whale watching
guys we're like oh well we're gonna have
to reschedule and they go rain or shine
no cancellations
I was like I was like are you serious
there's a hurricane do you want
to go whale watching is it a hurricane
or no refunds baby I said I was like all
right I'll see you there rain or
shine have that boat ready
they eventually they let us reschedule I
think I think once they saw the news yes
morons hey but hey Sailors watch the
weather report
the whale the whale
does it does its own show right I wish I
could coordinate with the whales
I wish I could coordinate with them man
I really want to see a blue whale out
there I've never seen a blue whale
they're out there uh yeah mating
this time of the year I think they're
mating off the coast that would be
really special have you ever seen a blue
whale Gabe
I've seen a way out baby a gray whale
might not a blue one yeah that'd be
interesting yeah
so um
all right
so you keep posting pics with that girl
how's that going
it's going good
is it is there a romantic connection I
keep asking that I'm just fascinated I'm
sorry for prying
we have connections there's a connection
yeah
I like connections
how much are we connecting
very much we like we like things you
know we're like almost everything we
like to kind of enjoy okay part of
mating mating is mating but yeah
hold the phone
mating is having sex isn't it oh mating
I thought mating like meeting together
like meeting a mate
no he said mating that man said mating
he knows what that means mating mating
means that you are going to basically
have a child with her sexually
right sex
you know oh okay so I didn't know what
that meant that doesn't mean by like
Making Connections I like made mating is
beautiful I mean it's one of the
beautiful things of life
or you could just have a homie that you
call your mate Maybe
Yeah just something like that not May
team
[Music]
you don't call her do you no okay
all right Gabe
it's gonna be a crazy weekend I hope you
stay dry out there all right
if they're from Back East it's nothing
it is so strong it's kind of like that
damn stores and
well it hasn't rained yet Gabe yeah
we'll see you know what I mean let's
pray let's pray for our easy one all
right uh nice to hear from you Uncle
Gabe
okay in my dick
on my tits lick it up up my
eyeballs and fried brown cheers oh nice
on my brown tears coming down my
face like shitty Virgin Mary
My Eyes Crying brow chairs and
and constructed
licked it off my mouth
you know some people see Virgin Mary on
like a grilled cheese
I saw Virgin Mary and my toilet bowl
I don't know
it's hard to improvise this you know
every week
all right how's cameo
come back Virgin Mary
how's Cameo going still good oops it's
still okay yeah
what are you are you a couple so Uncle
Gabe guys if you if you have Cameo needs
he's your man if you guys want to say
hey Los Angeles I hope you don't drown
this weekend uh this is Uncle Gabe
saying grab a life vest I don't know
just an idea for people to request me
yeah
all right gabo enjoy your pizza all
right nice to see you nice to see you
all right all right thanks Gabe have a
good weekend love you buddy take care
foreign
we have so much fun all right have a
great weekend buddy have a great weekend
peace baby
always a pleasure always a pleasure to
hear from Uncle Gabe
um
can you believe those whale watching
people Rainer rain or shine it's like
the
rain or shine the visibility would be
like one foot
I hear a whale
come on man tell them to bring out the
whole ocean there you go
oh my dream
it's just really weird you know
sometimes you have like really weird
dreams and
yeah you explain it but it didn't sound
that interesting
dream stories are terrible one of the
worst genres of stories because like you
feel that right but dreams are not
really rational so when you tell the
story
yeah not interested dreams are about you
know feelings yes you can't really like
communicate you just list a bunch of
stuff that happened to you in a dream
it's like okay although this one was
pretty weird I think it might be
interesting oh and uh I don't want
anyone to try to dissect it though you
know no analyze that's definitely
happening they definitely we're gonna do
that right now I don't want any
analyzing I'm ready so I was throwing a
birthday party
for my brother you never do that okay
right so already in a dream world
love my brother no yeah well that's
never happened love ya I made on throw
parties for myself yeah
and
everyone's raging drinking I don't know
anybody here okay
and
I don't think and please forgive me I
don't think that I'm married in this
store but I don't do anything yeah
so everybody's drinking I go in the
backyard and all of a sudden this is so
I can't say it okay it's weird
oh
[Music]
it's weird
I know it's gonna be weird
it's a magical dream it was a magic
dream so I go and back
right
I'm contemplating if it's worth saying
I'm gonna regret it is it gonna kick off
a week's worth of uh divorcement
analysis
no there's no no I didn't I didn't even
cheat on you in the dream you you I I
wouldn't even dream of treating on you
wow
so I go in the backyard
and everybody
is
what everyone's a coupled up and I was
like what the they're in the pool
they're on the couch they're couples and
they're just
everybody's
God and I was like what the is
going on and you know my brother's
pretty milk toast I was like the hell
who are these people
it's a good question
Vince is interested Vince is always oh
Zach exactly it's just so vulgar it's so
out of pocket
[Music]
no I don't know them what's your
argument there's no family thank you for
clarifying yes yes it was your brother's
birthday he wasn't there yes
it wasn't a family party it was like a
razor with young Anonymous folks oh
Young no no
no I mean like you know
you know people I would say in their 60s
I would say in their upper around 30.
okay they were like 45. yeah 50. and but
again I didn't I didn't have sex with
anybody I didn't even cheat on you in my
dream but I walked I had to drink them
and I was just walking around
and I feel like there was people sitting
around looking to get coupled up and
have sex
what see this is the part where I don't
think it's gonna translate I was walking
around
and nobody wanted to me oh do you
know what this sounds exactly like the
story that Seaman told us at the bath
house he was like I walked in everyone
was what did wasn't he walking
around alone for a while you were c-man
no I was Bizarro c-man everybody wanted
his brother oh yeah you were
awesome everybody was like following him
around begging him
but it was like uh it was like I didn't
exist and I was like Wow and I wasn't
trying to anyone but I was like wow
I'm so vile damn I don't know why it was
such a self-hating dream because I
promise I'm not like that but I was like
I'm so vile I'm so repulsive like the
girls when they saw me walking they
would like look away they're like what
they're like don't look at me I hope he
doesn't think that I'm trying to that
I'm willing to him it was like that
and I just felt really bad about myself
in the dream but I promise I'm not like
that in real life and then I had a hard
time the rest of the week because nobody
want to me in my dream but I didn't
cheat there was no there was no family
there it was just a feeling of uh what's
your argument no Dennis Prager Rejection
it was like not even Rejection it was
just like dude you are so vile
you're putrid
like you're the ugliest person alive but
that's that was the dream I don't know
that ugly and stupid and I kept having
it it was annoying because I'd wake up
and be like God that was such a weird
dream
and it's so noisy downstairs with the
kids yeah because uh your family's in
town so it's pure chaos everyone's
having fun downstairs
as early as what
six a.m yeah
oh my God nobody wants to me go
back to bed
oh God nobody I'm so advised I'm so vile
so I'm really tired it was a hard it was
just it was a hard evening damn
I hope I that didn't I didn't do
anything to you right to make you feel
anything no I I just hope you don't
actually feel like that about yourself
no I don't
are you sure I don't think I do maybe I
need to psychoanalyze deeper
I mean the good news is that it's not
your fault I'm not going to swinger
parties or trying to
uh mate in the words of Gabe with anyone
it's not your fault anyone else
other than my wife
and so
I think I'm gonna be okay I'm gonna be
okay I wonder if it's your reaction to
the fact that actually
people have been thirsting for you
[Music]
do you think it could be an autoimmune
thing maybe you need to have Lupus huh
do you know there's symptoms of Lupus
where people would imagine they're at an
orgy and nobody wants to them
really specific yeah really Civic so
there it is
okay so glad I could open up to you guys
thank you for sharing thank you for
listening
yes thank you for sharing thank you for
listening everybody yeah
it's a sign of Lupus as saying it
I feel that let's see we all come to the
top of the show stuff going on here
waiting for everybody to analyze it now
I mean what can you analyze from it see
now I challenge them there's gonna be
all right up all right I'll I'll read
them I'm curious it
I'll read them
so Tom Ward uh new friend of the show of
the Tom Ward show
he he uh was very appreciative of all
the love you all sent him so thank you
guys for being kind and gracious to Tom
here's his video teary-eyed
hey guys
I just got uh just got off Ethan's
podcast stage three podcast and I'm just
the support is overwhelming and I can't
um reply to all of you but I just want
to say after a tough year of failing
over and over again
um that just the support you guys showed
me today needs more than you'll ever
know so thank you so much you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah he has a wife and kids too oh
really yeah
but uh that was nice that you guys um
that you guys were so kind now
everybody's like I'm just being a little
cautious because you guys know the life
cycle of this type of stuff they come on
we love them and then somebody finds one
thing about them and then we ruin his
life
on accident not purposely right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
and there's a lot of really interesting
ones I kind of wanted to look at them
I don't understand the theory he had on
unlisting some of these like let's go to
video I understand the theory but I I
you're right to tell him to just go
ahead and play it back so and Emma
Chamberlain was his number one
almost a million look at this little
hoodie the honey the muddy hoodie
he said in when we spoke with him that
he wanted to kind of revamp and be more
business focused unless like social
media influencer Focus I can see
unlisted all of these but you know what
yeah I guess I can see where you come
because it's a lot of like adolescent
Tick Tock stuff exactly and he's a
little bit on the older side I guess he
maybe misinterpreted what Emma
Chamberlain is because she's
she's not in that world I feel like
she's above all that so I would leave
that one up if you wanted to take a
little Huddy down or the sway house I
get that
you should remove those um no I'm
kidding I'm kidding leave them all up
leave them all a little but they had
Addison Ray and he got he got these
people before they got super famous this
is interesting yeah some more dubrick of
the crew members more do he's in deep
with the dubricks
the dubricks
Garrett is a dubrick guy isn't he or is
it a shingo that's a shame not anymore
though they're not associated anymore
really they had a falling out they
haven't posted together since uh he was
Shane was canceled oh he lost Garrett
Watts Garrett and Andrew who was his
camera person they left together and
they had a podcast and I don't know if
they still film together but they're
great yeah they were doing some pretty
interesting content like Shane Dawson
content watching it yeah yeah good
really give me a link I want to see how
they're doing
he did a few haunted series that did
really well yeah Rice hall Addison Ray
Bella Thorne I mean she's a legit
celebrity you know God damn he did all
kinds of work up in this Jason
Nash from four years ago this man came
back
[Laughter]
which is interesting because he got 40
88 000 which is not a little but over
four years you think he'd come back now
he has 300. it's his fault Jason get
your together Tana Zane
I mean damn boy Larry
we mentioned this when we were talking
to him and you know he you kind of
encouraged him to give it one last shot
and to try and switch it up the content
a little bit
but genuinely Tom if you're watching if
if you decide this podcast thing is not
for you I think that you have a career
in being a Booker like and unironically
you with almost no following were able
to secure really big names and I don't
know that that isn't something everybody
do he said he had a background in sales
which makes sense he was able to sell
himself really well so I don't know I
think you know if he if he if the
podcast thing doesn't work out he may
have a future doing that kind of work
right and the good news is that his
recent video with Jason Nash is up to
2.7 thousand it's a big boost so we're
moving or we know the podcast was at
seven thousand so we're making moves out
here
but I am really curious I told him go to
your next
um interview and mix it up
I don't know if you watched the whole
tomorrow yeah
that was pretty interesting but um
people are like hiring for a book or you
need to go on a show you guys need to be
best friends forever I am down to be
Tom's best friend forever but we need to
give it a little bit of time before we
make a move because
these things have a you guys know things
tend to change on a pretty quick basis
so we're just gonna feel it out you know
because who knows he might I said I tell
the guy mix it up he's going to go into
the next interview and like take his
dick out right I'm like not like that
not like that no no we're rooting for
you just saying you never know man yeah
because he said who did he say he's got
uh David right
yeah that's not happening you don't
think I know he messaged me he's like
David canceled oh no I was like well
yeah
probably knew that was gonna happen
although if I can put my theory out I
don't think David was going to do it
anyway
because he's not doing presence's
controversies you know I mean he's not
he's not sticking his neck out for
nobody
it's not nobody he has a relationship
with him he had an interview he's had
him yeah obviously and other vlogspot
people
that's true Jason was on there
Jason maybe he was he was enticed by the
300 View
okay
oh that's right okay Ethan yeah
no look at what cam just said there was
a was Patrick Bet David yeah that was
the guy that you thought he actually had
a good opportunity to uh get a great
interview with Patrick Bet David I know
he he's got a terrible name because I
can never remember it either and every
time we bring him up you're like who is
that we've gone through this so many
times it sounds like a sentence like
Patrick Bet David what oh this guy okay
we've done this many times
okay yeah definitely this guy's a big
deal he's got he's got Patrick vet David
Patrick Bet David what
[Applause]
I don't understand what the what you're
saying man
so okay yeah I'm going to be watching
and uh we're we're all rooting for you
Tommy Boy
you know
let's do this brother
brother
um all right let's let's get off this
yeah uh this was really crazy
you know everyone's talking about the
weight loss but this picture is probably
the best before and after comparison and
I can't emphasize to you guys just how
like at my Peak fat when and everyone
was like oh you're so fat I knew I was
massive but I would look in the mirror
and be like I don't look that different
is that so interesting I say I don't
look that different yeah and now seeing
this I was like holy yeah man
put an apple in my mouth and
put me over an open flame no not funny
ah just I mean it's funny but
no but I it's and it's shocking to see
it side by side yeah that that is a lot
I feel like the one from the right is
like
when people show me pictures of us from
like 15 years ago
15. yeah
thank you yeah I mean it's one year
difference though
[Applause]
so that's good you know it does make me
feel bad in this
it genuinely feels like the people who
hated me respect me more now it's insane
and it makes me genuinely sad yeah
because I feel like this whole thing was
so much out of my control right
and I have so much empathy for others
who suffer from the same kind of
addiction
they people really hate fat people right
they don't take them seriously no
you know and actually what's what's
kind of interesting related I've been
wanting to talk about this for a while
so there's this viral country song
uh uh that's being shared from everybody
from Joe Rogan to Matt Walsh
uh have they talked about on Fox news
yet I believe so yeah yeah I got a lot
of coverage whatever it's really
interesting and and it's related to fat
people in an interesting way let me find
where this is
it's the Mumford and brother Sons yeah
Brothers sons that sounds incest that's
that's the joke
it's a joke yeah but he does look like
he does Dewey do incest right right
adult and he's doing like the folky
Mumford and Sons thing what's your
origin so here it is this is that joke
there all right I don't like jokes
his name is Oliver Anthony I thought
already but
and he dropped this song Richmond north
of Richmond
okay okay
and I don't know why every conservative
is freaking the out about this song
Everybody's sharing it everybody's
talking about it it has 21 I just love
it they love this goddamn song and they
love this guy 21 million views after
nine days this man was literally nobody
huh
um the
the lyrics are quite interesting
it shot up to iTunes number one chart
whatever that forever that's worth I
don't know I think it's worth something
right I mean that's still a big deal
it's really number one
yep and another song of his is number
two another one number one ain't got a
dollar ain't got a dollar cause all them
fat people on welfare he has another one
at number six there oh my God
I've got to get sober I can't get over
all these fat people on welfare got me
drinking
it's like that
so um what's interesting so let me show
you kind of the road map of how this all
happened
so the song was uh released
on a random Youtube channel which I just
pulled up
it's created by our two broke college
students with a passion for soulful and
real music
by the way I I'm skeptical now in my
older ages of people that describe
anything they do as real oh yeah
everything else is fake you know because
that quickly goes to like oh we can't
believe anything including facts and
science well it's just straight straight
arrogance it's straight like uh
delusional it's like okay you don't like
other people's music but I mean still
music still real music
um
he usually was getting 15 to 20 000 per
song now 20 million he's all over the
top charts wow
um so he that's to clarify that's the
channel was getting that many views not
the channel is separate from the artist
oh
so what's okay what's the significance
so that channel the uploads other people
the radio West Virginia channel oh they
re-uploaded it that's actually where it
was originally published they got they
did it with him
so here's the original post
um
and yeah here it is you know
here's one Virginia like go to videos
yeah
and scroll
past these so you're down eighteen
thousand twelve thousand and there's a
couple that are you know five thousand
but then I saw one that was like 200 000
so you know they're getting some views I
like folk music I'm a big fan of uh
folk music and all the roots of rock and
roll and all that I mean I'm into all
that stuff yeah so I'm a fan of the
genre
and I Really Love Lil Nas X Old Town
Road I mean wow
that's one of the most my love for folks
authentic expression of folk music right
there
he's a Libertarian so he claims that
Richmond north of Richmond is about
human trafficking
well there's a line in there about
Epstein's Island
that one line so it's all about okay
got it I don't think he was saying it
was all about it but it was one of the
many things that he's concerned about
that he's talking about so I want to
show you how this happened so Matt Walsh
and we all know he's like the biggest
transphobic freak genocidal
absolute Maniac just a demon I mean
truly and it's and it's most
uh literal sense okay I was born in hell
the main reason this song resonates with
so many people Matt Walsh said
it's because it isn't political
it's because the saw is the song is raw
and authentic we are suffocated by
artificiality everything is around us is
fake but a guy in the woods pouring his
heart over his guitar is real hmm
we ain't no City Slickers no more boy
bring me back to the country Old Town
Road Virginia we always missed you for
Journey let me give you just a taste of
it so you guys don't have to wonder
so Matt Walsh people like you wish I
could just wake up and not be true but
it is all it is yeah
um moving so Joe Rogan lost his
mind about it
posted it I mean the people who are
sharing this kind of tells you all you
need to know about it I mean genuinely
you know
first of all if Matt Walsh suggests to
listen to any form of Art
what the is this Joe Rogan wait
this wasn't this small yeah no something
weird about the version of it that he
posted so anyway it doesn't it looks uh
it looks normal on a phone but on
desktop it's like okay Legend
what a tech savvy King
um this had almost a million likes so I
I can only imagine how many views it got
yeah I love this song Joe said you can't
fake authenticity why do they keep
harping on the arms like saying the same
thing already same thing they're all
it's almost like they're aligned they're
messing almost like they all decided to
post about this random account on the
same day he's so authentic
like nobody's authentic anymore
yeah
you can fake authenticity and he tags
him Oliver Anthony music as in an
abundance Richmond north of Richmond so
everybody loves him
Jack prolapse
well his name is like Pro Z I can't say
his name right so I always just write it
on the docus prolapse well that's what
that's what it makes me feel that I'm
gonna do whenever I read anything he
does so it's apt Jack prolapse who was
basically how would you just is he just
a white nationalist I mean how would you
describe him by the way I have a
question some people are saying industry
plant and like I've been saying that
about other stuff too and I'm just
curious like what is the concept behind
an industry plan and why would anybody
want to do that okay that's a great
question because people are saying that
about Bobby yes that's that's where I
saw it but so this guy is literally an
industry plant and I will show you
exactly maybe allegedly we think so
alleged let's not say uh 100 well in
your opinion even buy what they cut what
they admitted to he's a plant in my
opinion yeah
yeah so so we'll get to that and that's
a great question here okay okay so Jack
uh prolab says don't even remember the
last time a new song hit me like this
um
that man doesn't listen to music like
that he's Patrick Bateman he just like
stares in silence at his wall while he's
like
waiting like he he doesn't have hobbies
he doesn't do anything if people are
looking for this kind of music they
should listen to the band
sure no they're not authentic but yeah
the band is wonderful Rock folk band I
mean there's there's so much good folk
music
much better than this and that's I mean
I I still haven't fully listened but
yeah I mean listen he's telling we'll
get to it yeah be a shame if this amp
some went absolutely viral this
insinuation that
um they don't want this song going viral
yeah
uh it seems that they all really are
organized the way they're talking about
this here's MTG not the good kind Magic
the Gathering no
margarine Taylor gross
Titan gross I don't know what you prefer
he does look like a Titan
margarine Taylor grows like I'm not
taking music advice from MTG okay
this is the song that Washington DC
needs to hear it is the anthem of
Forgotten Americans that our government
no longer cares about
these are my people the hard-working
good men and women holding up America I
will fight for them every day he's from
the suburbs what are you talking about
yeah like your people it's not your
people so she's a corporate chill shut
up yeah there all are all these people
are
uh that's the irony of it Benny Johnson
who as we know is number one closeted
can I even say that I know the Hassan
always jokes about it but I feel wrong
joking about that yeah I don't I don't
love joking about something like that
yeah just a little I'm not gonna do that
I'm not gonna do that to you today Benny
but I do think you're a giant douche and
really pathetic
and not funny at all damn yeah I said it
damn dude Richmond north of Richmond is
the most listened to track in the world
in the past 24 hours this American
working man's protest song has millions
and millions of plays sung by an
off-the-grid Farmer and the countryside
with his dogs okay so the messaging that
is pretty clear right yeah he's
authentic he's off the grid baby he's
just a dude with a guitar in the woods
damn it yep
okay but when you look a little bit
deeper
and I promise I will play the song we're
going to look at the lyrics and it's all
very good
um but here's a right-wing guy who came
out and spoke
against it this is a right winger the
Maga Hulk I mean geez look at his name
and so here's what he said
I didn't want to comment all this
because Oliver Anthony seems like a
genuinely great guy but Matt Walsh
sanctimonious word vomit forced my hand
well we have that in in uh
we have that in common my friend there
was nothing authentic about this song's
rise in popularity Jason Hoth Howard
Powerton seems to be the key player
involved in the astroturfing campaign
astroturfing is essentially a plan
that's basically like it's another way
of synonymous yeah
he's the CEO of Reach digital which
helps media companies and political
influencers grow their social media
footprint exponentially Jason was one of
the first accounts heavily promoting
this song as he provided a background on
all of Oliver Anthony and his faith
Jason indicated that Oliver Anthony had
been contacted
to record the song Jason also admits he
even covered the cost to produce the
song
so who wrote the song and how did so
many big right-wing accounts have the
video ready to post simultaneously
you can like the song and its message
without gaslighting us into believing
this was an authentic viral hit by a
simple Countryman with a mic and a
guitar
launch a product get over 1.3 million
hits overnight was the article that Mr
Howerton shared on LinkedIn this is just
another conservative Astro turfing
campaign embrace it
um he's called out by his own
is he saying just like just own that
we're good at this uh don't get his
point
yeah they embrace it I'm not quite sure
how to take that because he sees it as a
W for like w the move for the
conservative movement to have this thing
yeah that is what it means he's just
being real you don't know what it's like
to be real Ethan we we need to uh we are
real with you right now okay we
need real authenticity like uh the Maga
Hulk
only the mega Hulk can provide so this
is the guy Jason Howerton
CEO of digital reach formerly an editor
at the blaze Glenn Beck
and so this guy started commenting
Oliver was about 30 days sober when
someone reached out and asked him to
come record a song for his YouTube
channel that song was Richmond north of
Richmond within days the song was a
viral on social media
okay but then it gets even the web uh
gets even stickier
okay
if you can say that can we say that
uh here is Jason's statement on the on
the topic
sticky men
um he had a whole thread about it and
this was like right when it went up like
what was the proximity of him posting
about this
no it was a dare it was like the next
day or maybe yeah he was the first guy
posting about it yeah
so this guy shared it and he's got a
whole thread about it This song is
called Richmond north of Richmond it's
been viewed millions of times the
artist's name is Oliver Anthony I just
got off the phone with him
with his permission I'd like to share
the story he told me that moved the
deepest parts of my soul blah blah blah
yada yada yada whatever He's Got The
Whole 30 days sober yeah Born Again
Christians found God all that good stuff
but um
so here's this guy denying it as he's
being accused of astroturfing Jason
stickyman
so he's responding to the Maga Hulk he
says is this actually a thing I'm
incredibly flattered that y'all think
I'm capable of manufacturing a once in a
decade viral moment
flattering to yourself truly quite the
compliment once in a decade
show me the the gold blue dress okay
then we'll talk
Oliver could have posted that song to
Myspace and would have found a way to go
viral you'll need to touch grass
okay so the the the the argument the
arguments begin plot denial yeah but
then Diane bongino
who is has a name that sounds as dumb as
he is one of the rare times where you
can be like oh Dan bongino that guy must
be really dumb and you're right he is
bongino
who are geniuses out there but he got
pissed because he's one of these
right-wing hacks okay
he's like I don't know what's the deal
with this guy he's like number one on
podcasts all the time Facebook I don't
get it
but here's what he said Jason works with
me Jason is a great guy who texted me
last week Blown Away by the emotion of
all of her songs he texted him before
the song came out he's saying right
last week what's the timeline here
uh yeah the song came out on August 8th
so it was 14th when he posted this yeah
and it didn't go viral for a few days
after yeah August 10th is when it was
about in his effort to defend him
he's essentially outing this as an
AstroTurf project oops so he goes yeah
we've been talking behind the scenes
about this for a week Jason wanted to
help him he flew from California to
North Carolina
to help him oh get the message out oh
okay yes that's what he does he uses
digital platforms to spread the word
mine included this hello
doesn't have a clue about what happened
you literally just confirmed it yeah
imbeciles like this blow
are what decimates our movement they
open their big mouth about they
have no idea about while sitting on
their fat asses again
this is the fat hate yeah it's a Common
Thread throughout this story as you'll
see they're fat asses criticize the
doers this guy
and then didn't Joe Rogan also
say something about him or is it just
the bongingo
uh here's Matt Walsh the
the demon he was born in hell
he's actually his mom and father are
both uh demonic that show the leftovers
which is a great show by the way thank
you
uh the feelings zombies I'm sorry to say
perfect and fake in my opinion
the song was produced by a right-wing
influencer named Jason Howerton look it
up
km says Matt I like Oliver Anthony's
voice and he seems like a nice guy but
his lyrics you have to admit are
simplistic and politically all over the
place the stuff about taxes and Welfare
is pure establishment Republican stuff
okay uh and please stop this too because
I've seen a lot of this
first Oliver Anthony was not Astro
turfed Jason Howerton offered to pay to
produce his his album in the future like
he didn't produce the song nope that's
not one bangingo said
bangingo said he contacted me before
this came out and flew out there to
help him all right long they made him go
viral he sang if you want to make an
album in the future I'll pay to produce
it uh how did it go viral well
somebody posted it on Twitter and a few
big accounts saw it myself included and
we liked it the guy who asked you so we
posted it and a bunch of other people
liked it okay so what is so
great about this song You Might Be
Wondering at this point well let's watch
it okay and by the way this is kind of
interesting theory on the astroturfing
doesn't get claimed oh they want people
yeah I was gonna say how it doesn't get
claimed it's semen bad for me
right that's okay
and it's published on Apple music and
Spotify and everything so they've that
that's a conscious decision which I I
appreciate but I think it does say
something yeah thanks Oliver so here's a
good old bar obviously you can tell
about bushy beard
got all kinds of Critters from Last
Supper hunting in that thing Boy tell
you what me
so here it is
I've been selling my soul working all
day
overtime hours for pay so I can
sit out here and waste my life away drag
back home and drown my troubles away
it's a damn okay so that's good it's
like good folksy stuff so far
you know my crops died in the government
don't like me
my wife my brother
and I'm lonely well I haven't seen any
of that yet I'm just saying you know I
know how folk music goes
what the world's got into for people
like me people like you but I could just
wake up and not be true but it is okay
[Music]
these rich men North the Richmond Lord
knows it all just one
[Music]
yeah looks kind of cool thank you Zaki
the dollar ain't well it's like a
hybrid electric right it's mainly for a
like slide guitar oh I see I see is it
fancy oh it's like a Bluegrass
instrument
um this this verse starts to go off the
resolution he goes
he goes like yeah man working people
just have it and he goes the Richmond
north of Richmond they want Total
Control
the Jews no I'm kidding I don't know
uh but it's time
so the dollar ain't and it's taxed
to no end because of the Richmond north
of Richmond
okay
okay nice
[Music]
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not just miners on an island
somewhere that I was like the what
did we say about mine he goes I wish
politicians would look out for minors
okay
and not just miners like kids on an
island somewhere oh so what other kind
of miners are we not looking for
coal miners the Kohl's from Western
Virginia okay okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
I was on the farm I'm working man and
now we talk about Epstein the what
that was such a weird Epstein I wish the
politicians look out for the miners
[Music]
yeah maybe it's that
I mean he yeah he's saying they're
the miners yeah yeah you don't
you don't understand that line
the the miners on the island thing he's
talking about politicians at which
they'd look out for coal miners and not
be con kids on yes I know that
damn okay
you were saying well I was actually
confused yeah oh I was confused he says
they're looking for they're looking out
for minors coal miners well Dan already
said it you know you just said the damn
thing
um where are we
uh oh I just saw the obese yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so that's fine wait where I lost my spot
in the lyrics
um
the uh fourth paragraph down one two
three four I'm doing my mom thing
look at this I'm looking at this like
this
it's all over for me folks Deez Nuts
yeah okay I wish them yeah
[Music]
okay then I was like yo we're talking
about Epstein and then he goes people
are starving in the streets
because fat people
are taking all the welfare like the fat
it's the fat people that are destroying
I mean read it like exactly how he says
that he says Lord we got folks in the
street ain't got nothing to eat
good
and these obese milk and Welfare
so the theory here is and he he mentions
fat people again in the songs but like I
I haven't I haven't traveled America but
like educate me they're all they're the
most obese people in the world yes
that's what I was gonna ask they are I
mean that's not a secret the southerners
the they're they're I mean like those
obese people that he's talking about
isn't it like a lot of people around him
his family I mean friends listen Oliver
hey he's complaining about him yeah a
little husky you're a little husky
kind of like
kind of like trading all of his people
no like a like a like a flash Trader but
it's like oh you're such a um you're
such a down-to-earth guy let's let's see
what do we what was the message it's not
the capitalist fault thank you you know
what I mean it's not Bill Gates Elon
Musk Jeff Bezos that are destroy are the
reason why your friends and family can't
afford to have insurance or buy food
it's the fat people's fault because they
eat welfare and they get they get checks
from the government to buy food food
stamps I was like yo
that's crazy but here we go the next
line is about fatties too
God bless them
God if you're five foot three and you're
300 pounds away why did you have to do
that five three three sorry Oliver what
do you weigh you don't look at that
skinny why is he like you're okay I'm
sorry but like
why are we out here what what is this I
don't remember the Bob Dylan line where
he's like fat people are pieces of
well actually what's funny is um
Randy new Randy Newman has this song
um also uh cam just found this link but
uh
West Virginia the states he's from is
actually the fattest state the baddest
State boy there you go I didn't want to
say anything like no you're right on
come on what's the skinniest state we
see there on the West Coast
is it California I don't know sure it
looks like it to me brother dorado's
slower it looks like looking light blue
to me maybe you should come join us
while we're not fat what is there no
data for nobody's here baby this is so
weird Lord is off the chart they didn't
even rate it
that's interesting yeah
no way yeah here and then he goes so he
goes well God if this makes no sense
it's like the main theme of the song all
of a sudden this makes no sense how did
we go from like working people on trucks
just trying to live by because they're
like complaining about fat people well
that's at welfare because like folk
music is always like us us working folks
against you know the big wins the the uh
the capitalists the G-men but no the
real enemy is the fat people who are
taking all the welfare that's crazy
that's straight astroturface if they're
on welfare I mean those people need help
why go why are you going after them
hello yeah oh oh we have a squeezy in
the chat what a great this week
I was telling you about the yeah
anything okay
just because okay your mics are down
well
I was just telling Ela about the that
they all came and visited and it was so
nice
it just arrived yesterday my sister and
brother so I wasn't here but
I wish I could have met you guys
yeah it was really nice you guys were
really they were great really you had a
good time hanging with you guys also 500
euros okay friendship
so I see you that's what we were saying
French PewDiePie
um obviously none of us are French
speakers other than Ian of course oh my
God our resident Frenchman East learned
it on Babel but yeah I I went down the
rabbit hole and he is pretty massive in
the french-speaking world he's number
one he's the biggest YouTuber yeah and
uh his friend
um one of his friends Noel
she was she's like a big fan and she was
so nice it was so nice to meet her shout
out to all you all you four guys though
uh was a pleasure he said thanks for the
prolapse video
oh what'd I say her name was Noel why
did I say that well I know it's it's
Chloe what's your name why do you say
Noel Merry Christmas Chloe is there any
well because the letters are similar
n-o-e-l what's your name yeah yeah sure
let's go with that I'm just I'm trying
to debug my dyslexic brains dyslexia
I know it's Chloe anyway
they're actually both the girls with
them were named Chloe
owies what are the chances about that
um Hugo oh yeah Hugo was the other guy
yeah they're all they're visiting from
France also total sweetheart real
interesting guy
um the other Chloe was very nice it was
really going to friends so bad well they
invited us to stay with them so
yeah they said come here we'll take care
of you I said okay you'll regret that
no but uh he said thanks for the
prolapse video they wanted to see the
pro level
[Applause]
thank you squeezy I hope you guys are
having a good time on the rest of your
trip and uh
really nice connecting with you guys
anyway
um this Hugo guy is also a big he does
news I think
uh yeah he's a tick talker I think
primarily and has a huge following as
like a news tick tocker does he talk
about huge news wait and he was was he
the one who interviewed uh yeah
interviewed Christopher I'd like to
check out his you're like what the
his last video was an interview with
Christopher Nolan oh my God I'm like
listen Hugo I love y'all but where's my
Christopher Nolan
good for you man you pulled him you know
how to pull him
who's your Booker Tom Ward
people seem uh a few of them seem lost
in the chat what we're talking about oh
they had visitors yesterday we did a
hard Segway yeah we did we had some
folks visit us who are French YouTubers
or in French royalty basically they're
they're good friends with the song yeah
they came with this yeah and Hassan made
the connect because uh one of them is a
massive fan of the podcast and watches
all the time so Chloe yeah shout out I
love you she was so cool she knew
everything I love that like all the Lord
you are so awesome that's why the
prolapse video happened because she was
like she's curious so but anyway so
anyway let's get back to the song We
sorry about that crazy they're Oliver
Anthony
um so Oliver Anthony so he's there's
more lines about the fat people I cannot
believe that now it's just turned into
like fast but I was like I'm blown away
so listening to this and then seeing
who's who was uh sharing it I was
thinking like
he really actually just hate fat people
yeah and they're like they're starting
to become just like openly disdainful it
used to be that you wouldn't you
wouldn't say certain things out loud
right because it's rude but now it's
like we need to burn we need to kill and
burn the fat people for oil
for candles I feel like ever since Trump
like it became like you don't need to be
ashamed to be ignorant BMI King but you
did that that I feel like
yeah being a menace is good yeah being
ignorant I would point out this this
like thread is in no way new because
this is just this is well Welfare Queen
stuff which was like now you know nobody
in politics uses that phrase anymore but
that was like a Reagan thing of welfare
Queens where these Moochers the problem
is poor people getting government
assistance and not Amazon making people
in a bag yeah that's the dumbest
thing I could think psychotic like I
mean he's a total phony you're not a
folk hero you're a chill man
what are you talking about so it's all
astroturfing so let's go back
um
where were we fat people are the
problems
it doesn't even sound good it's so forth
and the fat people just ruin everything
and I hate looking at them I don't like
them let me make a small correction he's
actually from Virginia not West Virginia
okay what's their BMI
it doesn't matter uh but I mean um I got
confused because the uh the channel That
posted it is Radio West Virginia so
where Virginia go ahead
now here's real folk music
this is a man of the people he speaks
for me
memories
[Music]
West Virginia obesity rate for 34 no
this is Virginia this is Virginia no but
they're number 24 because you asked what
Virginia was okay I got lost in this
song
up the chimney seriously you got
so much hate
yeah just because you were fat basically
they don't say that but now I start to
see the same people being like okay I
guess he's done yeah now they're like oh
a rare Ethan W all of a sudden appears
right I wonder why but anyway here's
another Fat line I'm I'm causing it too
much but here's the next one
if you're five foot three and you're 300
pounds taxes don't not to pay for your
bangs the fudge rounds there you go so I
don't know if you caught that he says he
says well God if you're five foot three
and you weigh 300 pounds taxes ought not
to pay for your bags of fudge rounds
what
five drones fudge he says the fat people
be using all our damn money on fudge
how much fudge these fat people need
uh he says while the F and then he goes
young men are putting themselves fixed
six feet in the ground
because all this damn country keep is
keep kicking them down what's okay so
what about the fat people eating fudge
again chocolate
no the Lonely Boys they need help
only boys this is just so authentic it's
really authentic yeah
nothing speaks to me like
you know the idea of processing fat
people in the candles my brain in my is
going if you're five three and you're
three years
literally wait what's the BMI if you're
five three 300 pounds that's pretty
gnarly
is that a real can people I guess every
time you bring up BMI people get mad I
know I don't I know BMI is not real I
just want to get an idea for what we're
talking five three 300 pounds
is that a real is that a real stat
because I'm 511 and I was 250. three
five three is very short it is a real
stat
353.14 is what the BMI calculator says
can I get a can I get a photo of someone
five three 300 pounds maybe not but
maybe they're just on TLC or something
no you don't want to see that and maybe
they're also perfect in Beauty five foot
three 300 pounds
I mean do we really need to see that I'm
curious what it looks like like well who
are we talking about here I don't think
it matters there's a beefcake
yeah you want to see what that looks
like here here's your fudge Browns
Dave Batista
whatever his name is
that wasn't him
I don't know that's what came up when I
typed five pounds I don't know why
let's finish the song and then we'll
move on but this whole thing was pretty
insane if it's all just kind of generic
uh that's true he goes Lord Is It Anyway
about anyway over the welfare and fat
people anyway it's a damn shame men just
be working out here for no pay
whose fault is that
identify the cause of that one who pays
you the people at the top right not the
poor people
no living in a new world with an old
soul these Richmond north of Richmond
Lord knows they all just want to have
total control
it's just the chorus again
and then he says I've been selling my
soul working all day overtime hours for
pay okay
so this is the problem
this is the issue this is why people are
poor do you know how much of our
national budget goes to fudge for fat
people I mean it's insane
what's it like 30 or something
I think we spent like three trillion on
that why is nobody talking about fudge
fudge issues fudge rounds why is nobody
talking about fudge fudge is destroying
this beautiful once great country what
is a fudge round yeah what is it that's
some country yo it's a cookie these
are eating cookies y'all it's a
fudge wrap yo it's like a ding dong
cookies for you wow what country thing I
don't I never seen me a around here
boy you better see you before I never
seen one of them out in here isn't it
just a little Debbie products like every
grocery store literally anywhere it's
basically just a Twinkie joke basically
yeah awesome of course yeah they these
fat folks eating their Twinkies
em man we could but we could bottle
their fat and sell it to Saudi Arabia
keep our oil reserves High by processing
the fat folk and turn them into fire
that's I mean you know
I never had a fudge round I don't know
if I would if I would like it it doesn't
look good like it looks too is this
chewy is it crunchy what are we looking
at not a huge fan of these oh someone
says they are so good really
out here that's all we eat boy
we have fudge rounds for breakfast we
have fudge rounds for lunch and then we
have fudge round ice cream for dinner
Little Debbie know how to do it
I use all my welfare check bought me a
thousand fudge rounds
that's right
mm-hmm
all right there it is I wonder if his
family is like pissed at him like how
dare you talk about our welfare
Ethan has never been to Walmart I've
been to Walmart
don't do that to me I mean I know about
twinkies and Ding Dongs I never seen a
fudge round
so kill me bro
I grew up in a middle class family never
seen me a fudge round oh
all right I gotta take the
I gotta do our ads
thank you to our wonderful sponsors but
yeah if you guys see if you guys see
this song floating around know what a
giant BS it is and how weird this whole
thing is oh yeah and by the way he just
happens to have like a beautifully shot
beautifully uh mixed yeah out in the
woods like that's not easy
you know ain't no Poor Boys from
out here with the cameras and all that
we don't know nothing about that camera
we just thrown our guitars boy
I just know I move the strings and I
make a sound well I'm no more than that
bro
hmm
all right thank you thanks for listening
it's seed geek I love it
[Music]
you know we work with CG for a long time
they are they're one of our first
sponsors and I gotta say
I'm a huge fan of TV
okay
first of all
I'll tell you guys I'm gonna use Sea
cake because Queen B
Beyonce if I need to spell it for you
September 1st at the Sofi Stadium
[Applause]
all the pretty ladies all the pretty
ladies nope
all the
that's my favorite Beyonce song and I'm
super excited
to do that
best deal
um listen also the thing is you can look
for really good deals on siki and the
way the thing that I love about sea geek
that other
um services like this don't do
is that they give your ticket a rating
skill right
right okay they rate each ticket on a
scale of one to ten
green means good red means bad in terms
of the quality of the seeds and the deal
you're getting in comparison to I guess
retail you know sometimes it's hard to
know like I'll go out there buy Dodger
tickets for my dad and it's like
you don't know how hard you're getting f
you know
good to know they put all the tickets
across the web in one place to make sure
you're getting the best deal and every
ticket is backed by their buyer
guarantee and sea kick is the only site
that lets you return your tickets ahead
of the event with swamps
that's also massive you know
28 million downloads it's the number one
rated ticketing app
they love it man people throw it out
yeah there are over 70 000 events every
single day on SeatGeek including concert
Sports festivals
you you oh you're showing the app thank
you Dan yeah we're gonna see queen bee
on all the
all the pretty ladies
single
other single
but if they're pretty interesting
they're single and that's good for them
yeah they're about to have a good time
all the pretty Single Ladies all the
pretty Single Ladies
I thought it was the pretty nice ladies
all the pretty nice ladies I thought it
was the compassionate ladies oh yeah
it's getting a little wordy
it's all about fudge ladies oh they're
fly drowned ladies don't do it
no they they would never they would
never
um post Malone's coming up soon
blackpink is coming up soon at Dodger
Stadium Ed Sheeran which came on by Cam
that sees for that Coldplay October 1st
so many great great great shows coming
up and here's the best part about this
that you guys are gonna freak out about
tell them you came from after dark use
the code after dark and here's the best
part twenty dollars off tickets at
Seafood okay that's just 20 bucks here
you go okay here you go
that's 20 off your first purchase with
the promo code after dark make sure you
click the link in the description to
download the app this is sea geek right
now here's 20 bucks for you enjoy
I'm a huge fan thank you big time to see
geek
um
and uh thank you guys for supporting our
sponsor consider consider that
thank you
[Music]
uh moving on we've got next up manscaped
I like to keep my my manhood nice and
scapeg
[Music]
yeah listen
all bearded beasts
from stubble domains if you didn't
already knows manscape now sells beard
products
with their original product was a pube
cutter so now you don't have to use the
cube cover on your face
which I'm not I'm not ashamed to admit
that I've done because you go right in
the shower
if it's good enough for my you know
thick balls
then it's good enough for my face
because the dick in the balls is more
fragile all different more to protect
there you know just saying uh the
leaders in the below the waist grooming
change the game with their beard hedge
Pro kit and now they're going to step
further with the brand new handyman an
electric face shaver for a quick
convenient way to achieve a clean shaven
look I guess you need something a little
stronger maybe for the face
for the clean shave yeah
it's an electric face shaver for a quick
convenient way to achieve a nice clean
look whether you're looking to sharpen
up your neckline or give your face that
smooth finish that handyman has you
covered go to manscape.com and use the
code h3h3
for 20 off and free shipping
it's time to go from five o'clock
to oh yeah baby
or you could go from five o'clock to 8
am
early bird gets the worm
and in this analogy the worm I don't
mean
because the if the buzzer is the bird
and your dick is the worm you don't want
it to get the worm right Dan
yeah love ya
yeah no one likes a weird beard so say
goodbye with all the weird beard
troubles and stubbles with man uh
manscapes beard hedger
can you pull up a picture I want to see
that thing
I need Mine mine's in the mail
I have a hard time finding good beard
trimmers
I need me one of them
this thing is a jug or not first off
this cordless trimmer has a rotary wheel
that gives you 20 hair cutting lengths
but the fridge oh yeah look at that
yeah dude let's go
is there can I get a 360 of it
there it is there it is there it is
let's go nice
the beard hedger is a high-tech piece of
art and travel size package with a long
lasting battery universal charger and a
strong motor your face is your first
impression your beards your most
important accessory so make sure you
have the right tools for the job with
that beard hedger
you looking for something dare I say
smoother it's time for the bass head
your hand it's time for the handyman
thing they have two different levels
yeah even in the hedger
I don't think I'm handyman
what's the handyman can you pull that is
the clean shave oh once yeah I don't
like the skin I prefer to cover my face
as much as possible
so that when I go to the
maybe it's not time to talk about my
dream
save that
yeah but if you're like me you know a
clean shave is a hassle that's true the
handyman is a perfect compact tool I can
take it with me on the go and achieve a
clean shave looking without all the
effort so again 20 off
and free shipping with the code h3h3 at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscapes.com you use the
code h3h3 thank you so much to our
wonderful sponsor manscaped
thank you uh please consider supporting
them uh if you're in the market for
anything like that thank you guys yeah
made my way through that one
not bad
I'm gonna need to go do a potty break
that's a pregnant thing right
oh yeah it's already happening by the
way which is crazy because I don't even
have a belly yet but
um what are we are we doing the food
segment we should do that next
right now
you go pee and then we'll do the food
segment okay
yeah I'm not taking a pause to people so
as Ela goes off um
I'll just hit some stuff at the top of
the show here uh Elon is removing block
feature on Twitter it's kind of a
bizarre take I don't really understand
that
um
here it is
um block is going to be deleted as a
feature except for DMs
but what's funny is uh
where's our boy um because it makes no
sense under that
I don't understand why it makes no sense
it makes sense
because if you mute if you mute someone
I can still see your picture they can
still tag you they can see your posts
they can DM you so you can block them in
the DM which is good but you also still
just see it on a private browser
to get around like it's not that hard to
get around seeing someone's posts right
if they're blocked you know what I mean
I think it's empowering though to know
that you can just tell someone to
off in that way yeah I don't get why he
well
I have suspicions of why well pull up
that clip tweet
because elon's incidentally been
blocking folks
which is a little ironic I must admit
what's your theory on all this Dan
I think he looked at the back end and
saw that he's the most blocked person on
the platform and he's mad definitely
that's what I think happens he's got to
be he has to be the most I think he
realizes yeah like exactly like not even
just like he's number one but like
number two is like half the amount of
people dude that's so true because he
was forcing himself on everyone's feet
yes he must have been blocked really
really annoying yo you guys don't want
to see my nine gag names forced on your
timeline a terrible poster that's why
that's why people come here
raffle did you find that clip tweet I
for some reason WhatsApp isn't letting
me open there's a clip go look
for the clip that makes a lot of sense
so there it is uh no more blocking
on Twitter and I'm not gonna call it X
I'll be goddamn before I close
yeah I mean Elon Musk blocked Ken clip
and stain
it was just a really good legitimate
authentic journalist yeah he also does
troll a lot but the point being he's a
little trolling musk found a use for the
block function you know
we do a little
so okay
um shut up
the PNP defending H3 fans amazing I want
to show it to ELO though
it's one of you one of you degenerate H3
fans
got into some real deep
and PNP bailed your ass out let's go I
can't stay mad at her she's so I just
love her
this girl did some dude right
outside record with my great client Ela
you got to see this PNP saved the H3 fin
and she's she really up
silly woman
she spoke little girl with such big
attitude it's very short but she really
does she has a big attitude
all right I'm right outside of court
with my great client here I gotta really
tilt the camera because she's short uh
we see that David
take it easy on the H3 folks we love you
girl
and we really really crushed this case
today look she was under 21 and was a
lead with charged with DUI that's bad he
didn't even say alleged by the way he's
like I don't need to say it in this case
well you're under 21. and you were
driving drunk
and a resisting arrest and resisting
arrest uh it was like that her blood
alcohol content
.17
and we really thought this case hard and
at the end all these charges got
dismissed she's just getting a reckless
driving one year of probation not three
years and she's just got to do an
alcohol class and what uh write two
essays about the importance of police
they make your right essays I think that
happened to me once for something I did
either
but I would chat gbt that so fast
right ain't nobody at the yeah nobody
reading that anyway dude I want to
go back to school just so I can see kind
of yeah I want the challenge
with the resisting arrest for uh kicking
the office no one time a few times a few
times she looks so like sweet and
innocent this girl's a demon the way
she's just like
we love you though girl we love you but
like oh my God but really you gotta you
gotta take a hard look at yourself girl
I don't want to lose you I don't want to
lose you we need all the taking the
officer yeah stay safe girl underage DUI
and attack the police oh my God you're
too cute
you're lucky you're alive he's lucky
that she watched the show and she knew
who to call you think any other lawyer
levels dog definitely not PMP Works
Magic
but
you should be all right
oh my god do you think this is real I
mean you wouldn't lie about something
like this with it I mean if it was like
a maybe they're friends or something I
don't know no she looks so happy about
the whole thing why would she want all
this online
it's kind of like iconic to be in one of
those videos it is but maybe she just
maybe but oh my God is that she drove
drunk attacked the cop so that so that
this will happen oh my God please don't
die don't let that be the truth is .17
blood alcohol pretty high yeah
we need to talk to this girl and said
yes reach out yeah we need to talk to
her because this needs to be a wake-up
call for her we need to intervene
because what are you doing that you are
getting this drunk then driving then
kicking the police officer
so it's illegal to drive above 0.08
uh if you're higher so so she was a good
healthy what like four times over the
legal limit
okay girl well do you see the next
sentence there too it's point zero one
or higher if you are under 21 years old
oh wow so she was uh 2017 times the
legal limit I think I see her in the
chat because she just said oh my God
that's me no shot really but that was
over a year ago and oh my God I would
love to call
it was over screaming in my room because
I'm on the show that was a year ago why
was he holding on to that for so long
yeah what happened okay wait here's the
message oh my God that's me so can you
reach out to one of the mods or one of
the crew members on Discord I gotta talk
to you Juliana I must I gotta find out
I want to know how much it costs to get
David
work his magic too you know
there it is
love that huh
I mean I don't love that you were
driving drunk but no
I'm glad you're back on the street
look at this most sane H3 fan
hey come on buy her a celebratory drink
oh my God stop it David's laughing he
loves that comment
get her behind the wheel done oh my God
is she allegedly single
interesting any comment from David no
bro is single-handedly creating Gotham a
classic
he's laughing in that she definitely did
it but get your bag gank he said
allegedly
let's go
let's go thanks for helping the
H3 girly pops always
her future employees watching this like
and he just thinks that's funny that he
just potentially their whole life
up no problem
okay let's do the food stuff now
somebody in the chat is saying so this
is how you get on the show yeah get out
there and drive no
don't ever do that no you guys don't do
that we are not
we need to have intervention if this
happens again I'll tell you guys right
now
if there's another H3 drunk driving one
I'm not gonna watch it right because I
don't support this right she was the she
was the the natural the organic drunk
driver
drunk driving is not cool
and if you want to drink get an Uber 100
yeah so so this is it just never ever do
it it is death
yes it's almost as bad as being a beta
if you do this you will not get on the
show I will not discuss you ever
ever thank you thank you all right let's
do the food segment
that being said if you are watching call
I really want to intervene
I am curious why this was a year ago and
coming out only now
that's a good question I'd also like to
know that I gotta interview intervene
you guys I don't want to make sure I got
to make sure
[Music]
nobody listening
I said a joke and nobody was listening
so I panicked and nobody listening
thank you Sam the one person back there
all right I was just I saw this so
uncommon and it distracted me yeah me
too
oh what was it the one that I saw was
Eli it seems like TF is turning into a
fast fashion brand huh and I was like
that's why I wasn't listening to because
I was like what
and it's uh with the pace at which you
guys are coming out with new stuff is it
even fair trade and environment friendly
same as it's always it's the same as it
always been and it's the same as any
other fashion company we work a year
ahead and I mean
it's it's nowhere near fast
no nice try I don't know what you're
even talking about it's always been like
this a monthly release yeah we do
monthly releases we work really hard
I've been doing that since the beginning
you know
all right let's talk let's get weird
food combos we're hungry
yeah
she is 5'3 with a really high alphabet
alcohol level
[Music]
smells good Sam so what's the idea
behind this segment so okay as you know
as people know Ela is pregnant
yes and baby wants when you get pregnant
as often happens uh with pregnant women
baby wants
you there's a little something already
you get you get hungry which is unusual
you get Cravings you get intensely
hungry yeah which is fun I love pregnant
Eva although when I was 250 that was
probably right I feel bad so let's see
if I survive this one everybody around
me is trying to lose weight and I'm like
so who wants to eat
right
I know I'll have to I just got to join
you responsibly yeah
eat responsibly
is there a certain amount of food that I
can eat that makes it illegal to drive
is there like a food alcohol a food
blood food
this man this man had three Quarter
Pounders your honor my mom's not safe
you know the dish you made yesterday
yes
that that knocks you out people fall
asleep not safe to drive not safe
so you know there's a meme in the that
pregnant women like weird foods together
something about the hormones it unlocks
new flavor interests this is like an
actual thing yes really I hear I mean I
think everybody's heard that at least
maybe it's an American thing I don't
know but it's like pickles
uh here I'll tell you guys what we have
as combinations so we have peanut butter
and pickles
which
could be good what
I'm wretching at the idea but it might
not be bad
Nutella and Doritos
sounds kind of I kind of with that
the tuna and ice cream is a disaster
what I don't think I can even try where
did that one come from blue cheese and
brownies
wait can I eat blue cheese I guess I can
well I just crumble actually can someone
look up as blue cheese
um yeah I don't know if blue cheese is
okay for pregnancy what's it called when
they when they heat it up pasteurized
yeah is blue cheese pasta tries to avoid
blue cheese products or only buy ones
that you if it uses pasteurized milk
it's okay can you see if it's
pasteurized the blue cheese you got
oranges and white bread nothing wrong
with that
Lay's chips and Greek yogurt nothing
wrong with that
sweet potato and maple syrup yum
soy sauce and mango that one's
interesting
okay so we're gonna try each one and
then you as the only pregnant person
here that I know of
um are gonna put them together on the
tier list okay yeah
so here it is and exciting to say that
you went to the doctor recently there's
a heartbeat yes
it was very um interesting it's just
like a tiny Dot
it's like the size of the Pea a lentil
your mom was saying or lentil yeah very
small and um but you can already see the
heartbeat it's like you see the flashing
so crazy it's so crazy like how does
that happen
that's just but always it's the third
time and I'm still like so
like it just feels like magic you know
it is I mean it really is you know
God did that God did
all right here comes our first dish I
think God dude it's drinking out
uh the peanut butter and pickle okay so
the idea here is to dip the pickle into
the peanut butter never heard of that so
it's like a celery stick
okay so here hold it up for the camera I
can't see a Stan because of the boat
shark that's it that's a good place to
start
[Music]
I'm gonna try that
a Bobby well well done on the pickle
choice
I don't like it you like it
really
[Laughter]
it's so salty I like it
because like the peanut butter is salty
no that's horrible
I really tried Eli I tried I don't like
it although there is interesting
aftertaste it's kind of nice
there is kind of a pleasant aftertaste
they kind of complement each other
in a weird way
prove to me that you actually liked it
I'll be doing this tonight at home
there you go see we're getting ideas
so
I know that we're probably going to move
this around a little bit
but if you had to put this on the tier
list what were you what would you think
s obviously being
like God's here
okay and D being
I would never eat this again
um I'm definitely
I'm definitely more under like I would
eat this again so where would that go a
b or a
B's mid you know would you go home and
try this
I think I would
that would be S then I kind of it would
have to be ass no but let's do a we have
this a and we'll see all right let's
start with that so this is already off
to a pretty interesting yeah this is
crazy
I like peanut butter
I actually like I'm okay with peanut
butter I don't love it but this makes
the peanut butter more tolerable
actually
wow
fascinating very fascinating up next is
one that I'm pretty excited about
Nutella and Doritos another dipping uh
set up here let me show you guys
a dollop
of Nutella which you are a fan of
I love Doritos I don't know how you feel
about them I love them
go ahead okay
somebody said in the chat I love peanut
butter and pickle sandwiches I guess
this is like a thing really I would try
that
I mean what's not too loud
Nutella and Dorito
if it doesn't say let's just not do it
yeah
because it's definitely not not okay if
it's not passion my problem with it is
like
they both have such strong wonderful
flavors by themselves I'm not sure I
would eat it
prefer to eat them together than apart I
have no problem with it you like that
she has not yet met a dish she does not
live okay love would you do this at home
yeah I like it so what's your name I
mean it would be very
irresponsible treat but I would eat it
no
you're pregnant girl I mean that seems
that's seems ass the way that she's like
she's pretty I've already had four okay
hold on is this better than or as good
as the pickle I mean it's Nutella this
is better so it's ass yeah I think it's
this
yeah
okay well let's say you were at the
kitchen there's a bottle of Nutella
a bag of Doritos
and a piece of white bread
what do you do
this is more fun actually wow that's ass
that's us
holy okay
damn
these results are surprising they are
surprising and you if you don't
tuna and ice cream I'm not even trying
yeah
I don't think I can even try it
I don't like tuna so yeah I'm I'm like
okay with tuna but anybody want to try
it I also feel like tuna is another
thing you're not supposed to eat when
you're pregnant I think tuna is fine but
let's let's just double check that
I feel like I remember something about
it might be because of the Mercury yeah
the Mercury
I think it's fine if it's just not a ton
of it I can tell you I'm gonna you can
hate it you can enjoy eating uh canned
light tuna albacore tuna yellow finch
tuna they're safe oh it's good for you
and your baby as long as you limit how
much you consume okay
yeah
so not so much different than the rest
of us
I will try a bite of ice cream just
saying you're saying you're not allowed
to have the ice cream if you don't put
the tuna on there
Ethan Eat Your Greens before Ethan
where's the tuna what try the tuna no I
don't I swear to God I can't do it I
honestly I need tuna I totally feel you
on that this is disgusting but you're
doing you're gonna do it I'm gonna do it
oh zero let's go but you might like it
you haven't there's not one you
didn't I'm trying to like get a pretty
small bite but also not too small okay
disgusting
I'm not hating it right
It's oddly like it works together
okay I gotta see if this is
you still will taste the tuna you're not
gonna like it all right so I took I mean
this is vile Lila I feel like I'm doing
a nasty challenge
ill
yeah this is horrific
oh yes oh no I feel like if I liked tuna
more this would be a good one
but I'm just not a fan of it oh
but they kind of work together
you guys does anybody else want to try
it you want to try it you don't have to
take your word for it you can try it
right now oh what do you think if you
would love me too I would oh you would
love okay yes I would oh Sam's saying
she would like it too Sam's gonna try it
okay
Ethan is traumatized we need we need a
new Fork share with me
yeah forks go ahead you know you're good
you sure
yeah
sure
I hate the checkpoints
it's really congealed
it's literally fine okay no what's good
it kind of works
so weird
I'm eating like dinner and dessert yeah
it's good
oh no
oh okay do you do you like tuna Sam
Olivia is running yeah maybe that's I
think I think you love tuna you would
love this I gotta ask Olivia when she's
done dying she's dying that is
disgusting it's like what it does in my
mouth is like
similar to what
Suman strowman does really not right
Jesus
oh no what is this one do you like tuna
Olivia
yeah I do oh you do yeah uh we have to
rate the tuna before yeah where does
that one go for you yila
um just because I'm not personally a
tune-up person maybe I would put it at C
okay so fairly low
um you would never do this at home no
never yeah yeah okay that's probably a c
we have our first C it might be a d i
mean
you didn't hate it I didn't hate it
though yeah it's a c it's a c
so it looks like now we have um
blue cheese so this is just for you to
try Ethan oh it's wait it's blue cheese
dressing
this is probably pasteurized oh wait
it's dressing I thought it was real
cheese it's just blue cheese dressing
that's for sure pasteurized
blue cheese this is Hidden Ranch
dressing pasteurized Lighthouse blue
cheese dressing
it says most if not all
uh commercially produced salad dressing
made with pasta you're good you're fine
on this dealer I mean if you want it's
salad dressing it's fun it's definitely
pasteurized blue cheese dressing is
always pasteurized and has to be in
order to make the dressing shelf stable
yeah okay I mean it sounds like it is
pasteurized
so you're supposed to dip now I don't
like blue cheese
this is gonna make this hard for me I
don't love it either I'm okay with it
sometimes
so we have the Brownie and the blue
cheese you cannot imagine this working
so far you've liked everything
[Music]
I don't like it you don't like it so
this is maybe our first D rating
I don't like it this was a pretty
adventurous pairing I must say
I just I like chocolate too much I just
want to eat it on its own right the
brownie is pretty good so here I go
all different flavors
you know when you just get a little dab
of it it's not bad
really like a little salty like let me
try this for you
you're going for seconds no no that's
pretty ELO I'm gonna do it for her like
there's just like a little dab you think
I had too much on there maybe and not
enough brownies a lot
[Music]
doesn't Elevate no
not working first I still don't like it
so it's a d okay
who could have guessed Bluetooth brownie
wouldn't work
surprising
blue cheese brownie
this next one is
I don't see how I could dislike this one
yeah like orange juice and white bread
it is weird but like what is there not
liked about that you know yeah I don't
see anything wrong here
buying this one Sam who came up with
this stuff
it was from a list of uh
like weird combinations of Cravings that
happen when you're pregnant okay I feel
like I'd like that yeah there's nothing
wrong here but try it out maybe you love
it I mean
this is just a new thing
the new Meadow
I'm gonna hit this
[Music]
nice
like bread and jam the dingas
oranges are very fibery
already what
like you chew it and there's just a
bunch of in your mouth extremely
wet the bread doesn't compliment that
you know it's hard enough to chew and
get a orange peel down
I don't need more I don't hate it
but I wouldn't eat it at home
that's a c okay yeah
how are you feeling are you surprised so
far at your enjoyment of these yeah and
if you weren't pregnant do you believe
that you would interpret these the same
no no I would hate everything that's
what I think
because the ELA really is not into I'm a
hater normally yeah
food
or stuff like this
he's taking an orange peel
all right up next
there's nothing wrong here Lays
chips and Greek yogurt there is nothing
let's go Oh I thought this was cottage
cheese
okay
is Greek yogurts a question like I
really check all these now you're gonna
like it the question is is it s here oh
good if you're like I need this at home
I think you would like this even if
you're not pregnant
I'll tell you right now this is just
salty ships
those ships are so salty it does a lot
of work right quick yogurt
yeah that's great I mean I probably like
sour cream better mm-hmm
but this is healthier you care about
that
no we have another ass I mean you're
both liking it it's not as for me but
it's not my choice it's not my life um
probably right on their s
on the line
a well it's yeah okay
you would eat this
I would eat this if it was out on the
table Yeah Yeah
no surprises there
I don't see this one being any problem
sweet potato and maple syrup
oh wow there's no problems here
oh my God that was so good
it's like a pancake
but you know sweet potato was
fantastically nutritious healthy
so if this is good for you it tastes
good to you it's a great meal great
snack
healthy so here's how it goes
oh shut up doctor what do you know
taking our first bite of sweet potato
and syrup
[Music]
sweet potato is a superfood Apparently
one of them Super Foods super duper
hmm it's good that's nice
the sweetness kind of leaves before the
end this is nice and then just I mean I
like sweet potato one for everything the
thing is it's literally every every
first comment that you made he's had a
sound bite of saying the exact same
thing ready to go how the no you
haven't
the problem with this is I like sweet
potato it's it is sweet by itself and
nice you eat it with the syrup
when the syrup sweetness goes away
your mouth is used to the super
sweetness you can't really taste the
sweet potato in a good way
in order to comprehend you're gonna have
to bring it
comprehend in order to comprehend to eat
the uh the the omelet of knowledge
you're gonna need to break those
eggshells so so chill
uh a chatter said that in South Korea
they eat sweet potato with honey uh all
the time yeah that sounds good it's so
good it's really delicious that sounds
really good I'm from South Korea the
thing is like it's a really healthy
snack just he wishes
just a beast mode I uh
grape baked sweet potato
I feel like there's a chance I would eat
that at home because it's healthy so
it's probably would you go out of your
way to prepare this
because it's healthy
I might you might that sounds like it
because I've been craving so much
crap and like sugar and stuff then I'm
trying to not eat only unhealthy stuff
so I can make it for you too it's so
easy
so that's a nest here then that sounds
like that's a real snack that might
happen in our house right
yeah
nice very nice nice we're actually
getting ideas yeah
the last thing I expected nice so this
last one this one is a tough ride yeah
I'm not sure yeah soy sauce and mango
now mango is Incorporated in a lot of
Asian Cuisine yeah that was kind of my
only thought as well
and like a mango vinaigrette or
something I feel like that would be good
it's sweet and salty right so so this is
not a great mango it doesn't look right
let me taste well that might hurt oh man
yeah I mean it's still sweet but
absolutely very nice it's not where you
want your mango not the best showing for
mango today try the mango before you go
in just so you know
um it's not horrible it's not a ripe one
no it's not there
I normally love mango so I feel like I'm
not gonna like this
you're a purist yeah
don't take a big just a little dab you
know what I mean yeah you don't want too
much soy sauce in there
all right yeah yeah
he was taken a bite the mango soy sauce
her wheels are turning
it's not bad it's not bad
I guess I need to try it it's not that
bad
there you go somebody said Green Mango
and soy sauce is good I don't know if
that's a common thing or just something
they like in particular it's not
horrible but I would never do this yeah
which makes it probably
a c c but there was no Bees
huh see uh oh that's true see we don't
love it oh we hate it
well that's it I mean the orange was
should the orange one be see because
you're kind of neutral on that right I
just don't think that you would ever
make this
you would never if you saw bread and
oranges would you put them together no
yeah yeah that would probably go lower
than the mango I feel like the bread
yeah
so maybe the main goes B
okay brick but you would never do this
either
yeah what if you had we are working with
an unripe mango here right could that be
a factor yeah do we need to account for
that okay yes
give it a b
so
here we have it there it is I mean my
goodness we've really uh learned
something way better than I expected
yeah I thought you'd hate most of these
uh the S tiers to recap is Doritos and
Nutella
[Music]
and sweet potato and maple syrup yeah
congratulations to our two winners we'll
have to be preparing congratulations
give it up congratulations
we need to acknowledge the runner-ups
pickle and peanut butter yeah
one stole our heart as the first
contestant
[Music]
and of course lay chips and Greek yogurt
a fantastic showing I want to do
um really good
pickle and peanut butter
can like a wild card award because
that's the one that surprised me the
most there it is the wild card goes nice
yeah too pickle peanut butter
and the one thing we really did learn is
that blue cheese
brownie not good no not good and then I
would give the audience favorite award
to the to the sweet potato because that
one is also healthy
oh
so maybe the winner of this whole
contest there we are
foreign
look under your table there's a sweet
potato there for every one of you
[Applause]
that's right
enjoy your prizes everybody it's a sweet
potato for everybody at home you guys at
home stay sweet I'll see you next time
thanks for watching everyone
[Music]
[Laughter]
it would be funny to end like that all
right early day guys
that was fun yeah oh my God nice are you
still hungry though do you want to get
something I mean you didn't eat that
much
[Music]
well I have a little bit of a beef last
time we ordered pizza
there was a veggie on every single Pizza
did
yeah
why not order a
pepperoni pizza one a classic
Pizza okay I need to say something about
pepperoni pizzas a classic
you're not a child that is a psychotic
Pizza to eat
veggies
like I don't know you know I think an
overarching theme of this podcast show
needs to be slowly but surely working on
Love's diet well love I gotta and
introducing him to the beauty of
vegetables
he's going back to Sweden we've had a
big meal have you tried a cucumber with
salt on it like just cucumber with salt
a cucumber with salt yeah I like that
okay I like cucumbers okay ketchup too
okay you've lost me there wait love how
are you still hungry we ate
yeah dude we had a a wine bar
wine barbecue thing right before the
show
I forgot about that love I know that
feeling man I know that feeling there's
a lot of food too much I completely
backed that up bro this is an example of
your mental game taking over here I'll
still eat pizza knowing I've been there
man that's a dangerous road to walk down
yeah it was
I need help
so nobody else is hungry
what do you want what does Dan want I
I'm not particularly hungry yeah I don't
want to decide I can't take that
pressure get the camera off me
I just oh people are now people are um
saying I'm in no position to criticize
pizza toppings and I'd like to tell you
all
that of those that have tried it I see
this all the time in our community they
love it no
he's right on this I hate to say it but
his his weird ass Pizza it's not bad at
all it's even pretty good also people
thank you it's got it all it's you know
I mean it's it's like a symphony of
flavors yeah and I'm the maestro
you're the Leonard Bernstein exactly
look at my big ass junos people are
saying
about the pepperoni yeah apparently I
told you I'm sorry I feel like I'm not
even gonna debate that with you guys I
will back you up to the depths of Hell
on that one it tastes good but it's
psychotic I agree I even I would go the
tastes a little much the the pepperoni
is a little overwhelming but be honest
it is yeah it's strong but if man if
it's only Pizza there I'm gonna eat it
don't get me wrong and I'm gonna love it
they could it's not over the that Paul
is bad about being overrated right
because it's a good pizza it's just it's
on healthy it's pepperoni pizza on
health no I think it's like I I agree
with it it is overreacting yeah that was
your take was that it's massively
overrated it is it is over very
nutritious but apparently people are
disagreeing what the hell well I don't
give a if it's on how he'll eat
that anyways God damn listen you
guys when you guys criticize me
you're like I get it you like to eat at
McDonald's I prefer to eat at Michelin
star restaurants where they're you know
doing interesting thing they're they're
thinking their intelligence it's more of
a
analysis of food and Earth and life
itself I will say the um
spicy uh Italian pizza at California
Pizza Kitchen a good good pizza there
gotta say that Dan any comment about the
California Pizza Kitchen
it's the uh it's the spicy uh Italian
pizza
there there was no cauliflower or crust
when I worked there yeah we used to work
at CPK dude really yeah it's true yeah
maybe surf anybody famous ever do I
bring it up a lot do I you know what
it just is one of those things where
it's like everybody knows that about it
it's like it's come up you've mentioned
that a lot not intentionally but I go
huh I've heard that story a lot of times
sure it's like the Logan Paul Story how
many times have I told the Logan Paul
work
I get it man you're a worker you're a
man of the people
it's like the Logan Paul red car story I
haven't told it that many times I
haven't told that story in years
the Logan Paul what story with the red
car awesome what color is the car oh and
then he threatened to punch you yeah
you've told that like
a thousand times when's the last time I
told that story like a week or two ago
we did talk about it no yeah you last
week last Friday I think I'm not kidding
last week you told the story last week
wait but you know what you know what I
remember when we were talking about if
we should go to the stream exactly and
we were saying would Logan be there
right I think that's how but I didn't
bring up the damn the race car story
did you troll him twice are you talking
about two separate stories there's the
one where you saw you when he turned
around and he was like yeah that's the
only time I've met him you know it's a
great deep cut story though which like
you might have told it once when you
smoked crack that one time uh right
that's my crack story I've never heard
about that one your your Pizza Kitchen
is my crack foreign
Dan tell us what you want to eat so we
can move on I'm not I'm not the guy I'm
not that guy love says Pizza do you do
you accept or do you use your effort
show us with your thumb I I did kind of
enjoy that one with the cheese in the
crust oh that wasn't insane but
like once lives was enough for the day
like I was so full forever I did I did
regret eating that all day that's the
true Point that's something to consider
you know
Mexican
here just do like this I'll give you an
idea and you go or you just hit me with
the thumb okay okay Mexican
hey you gotta leave your thumb like this
okay racist and then you just go up or
down okay
um Pizza
oh we've got a reading okay okay
what about
um
Mediterranean that was good which one I
don't know whatever we ordered last time
was really good
Vietnamese
I don't know sushi
Sushi you're not supposed to eat while
pregnant yeah true I'm just trying to
say stuff so you get her thoughts down I
got you
a Taco Bell this is too General like I
need to know the exact places you know
Taco Bell
that's what maybe
go with your thumb
let's go okay
do I like anything there no no overrated
uh McDonald's
not today
um
Boba isn't food
I hate Boba I'm so out I'm out on it too
I tried it so much
breaking my heart I'll do it on my own
time okay I'm gonna say this and if it's
too rude just button it out
Boba is the Tom Ford of beverages
I don't get it I've tried it I've given
it a shot it's just not happening who
the is Tom Ford the designer Tom
Ford
clothing brand or
w
oh you said Ford right I did say Florida
because I was gonna say Tom Ford makes
great
you're you have a your man of class and
style
okay so then um
that's a permanent no
that then like we come to that
conclusion yeah Ian almost died last
year yeah right we're all out on
Chipotle
[Music]
so it seems like you're pretty
interested in pizza or yeah Taco Bell
maybe we should just do pizza
wait combination Taco Bell Pizza Hut
dude that's the real thing Am I Dreaming
right now how does that we're set up
perfectly
fine that's like a thing did they put
they have comment because they're owned
by the same company they put the tacos
on them no but they like they just have
both you can order both at the same time
I don't like that there's a song about
it too and there's a song about it too
much ingredients you I should just get
the Mexican pizza
that's a good thought is it good it
sounds like a lot of people swear by it
really yeah I'm not a fan personally but
a lot of people love it
so they're like they had everything
these knees I don't think it was
Vietnamese vegetarian options and had a
veggie sandwich right about me you liked
it yeah it's like Vietnamese inspired so
like I got yeah we should do that
chicken sandwich but I had like cilantro
on it so good
maybe we should do that
Maybe
we should
very good maybe let's make a decision
here maybe maybe
all right Ela sandwiches pizza or Taco
Bell
[Music]
play the stress music uh yeah yeah yeah
amp up the tick and clock well when the
club chews Pizza
out of those three oh uh definitely not
the sandwiches pizza or Taco Bell I
probably hit the Thai oh no I'll hit the
pizza if it's pepperoni otherwise we're
not getting pepperoni negotiating bro
what's Zaza Sam Pizza
let's do all all veggie pizza
you don't like any veggies on Pizza it's
amazing it doesn't like any veggies
veggies period black olives no
no it's not like even I'm not even
memeing this man does not eat vegetables
no no meat only that could become a
problem for you yeah I don't think so I
haven't when you hit 30 yeah you're
young still man you start to feel those
the problem starts showing yeah you're
gonna be old in one day and you'll be
like maybe I should eat a vegetable
nah
all right all right we'll get the pizza
order going we can buy kids uh salami
Pizza we can get you a we can get you a
pepperoni or would you do you like
cheese pizza
like no meat well cheese I mean it's
better than veggies
demo meat lovers Pizza meat lovers just
salami lovers let's go for it I mean
nobody else is gonna okay all right
nobody's gonna touch the thing
all right we'll work it out we'll work
it out we're gonna move on meat lovers
do they do half half
oh they probably do yeah that'd be a
good compromise yeah that's nice you
could get half a meat you want a half a
meat lover or half a pepperoni pepperoni
lover you're a pepperoni lover yeah so
we'll do half a pepperoni right thank
you very much I appreciate that all
right
we accommodate uh and cam do you have
any special requests
I'm a veggie too so anything Dan gets
I'm cool with
there it is yeah
I think every yeah everybody here likes
the veggie options so
we'll get the peps all right very good
extra cheese in the crust she's in the
crust
all right where were we Jesus Christ man
damn you really bothered me on Twitter
[Music]
me yeah what did I do I tweeted
something that really upsetted me
you read this and tell me how does it
make you feel uh
read it
I cannot read that why
this reminds me I have
that says MILF on it and this morning my
mom was like can I borrow this hat and I
was like you can but you don't know what
it says and she was like what tell me
and I was like I can't tell you she was
like tell me
and I was like I can't tell you you're
not gonna read this peeling back my
coffees clitoral hood awesome that is so
good
at least I've seen what a vagina looks
like
Sam explain yourself um unpack you know
what I mean I mean that's what it is
so the the clitor are so where's the the
clitoris on this is it the whole you
drink out of or is it the button above
it
like it's probably I mean it's got to be
under the hood right so I guess it's the
hole you drink out you're drinking that
thing
you know like Anatomy
get after it
all right Sam thank you for that image
I appreciate that pretty fire
pretty fired
making me feel that type of way
here's a snowboarder taking out
everybody on the slope
you know I love this
I'm a softy for people getting hurt
uh
here it is everybody enjoy
that's right
you got this
you got this and it's a tip then to come
into semen
all right here it is
do people do this where they hold
he's like holding on to a hook yeah
Bales oh no oh they're all going up that
way yeah yeah that's that's you put it
between your legs
he could have tucked his feet in on that
one he's taking out what then that's
gonna be 10 people
wow like a video game like how many
people you can take out it looked like
that was his goal now I've never been
I've been skiing once but it was a chair
I never said this seems pretty sketchy
like this would happen yeah yeah or one
foot fell out and then it was all over
and he know there's no escaping this
face
so I've done this you have yes I've
fallen and taken people out
in this situation yes this except this
exact thing happened to me I didn't take
out that many but took out two people
yeah
how far away apart were they uh huh how
far apart were they it was right by me
the the people it was like a slope right
next and I had after I took them out I
like started gliding and then I uh kind
of I tried and I went down the slope
like down the woods and I had to
walk down like a wooded wooden area
because I got out of bounds
yeah I feel like that's got to happen
fairly regularly like look at this
this is madness dude people got
up though
this dude here really ate
Sam I don't need my usual I'm I can mix
it up
what do you yeah I I stand in solidarity
with you guys for real Battlefield
but you want a veggie pizza regular do
you want baked like extra bacon
I was gonna get a few different ones so
if anyone's veggies
there's this one this this second guy
gets absolutely bodied oh my God yeah
and that one that woman did not need to
go down like he could have tucked it in
for her look at this
what did you do man you could have saved
that lady oh
let's watch let's watch a frame by frame
here okay
or it's not letting me do that
unfortunately so if you watch his skis
there's a certain point right here he
tucks it in
yep let me kicks his legs out yeah it's
up whoa that one's bad too
so people are saying couldn't you like
dig into this no what they do here is
they drive a machine up and down to make
it like pretty much eyes so if you start
gliding you're yeah it's like super
slippery yeah they should put
okay all right listen I'm not of this
world y'all got your own problems
but there it is
did you hurt anyone love I mean I don't
know I just I can never check that no no
because you were falling yeah I was
going down like a slope I had to walk
for like 20 minutes were you hurt no no
no no no just cold skiing or
snowboarding skiing first time ever oh
unless that was at first I had it first
and last too yeah mine was awful the
first time yeah I think I've told this
story so I'm not gonna do a California
Pizza Kitchen if you guys know about my
first time skiing
yeah you have yeah yeah so you guys know
the story you can just play the sound by
Zach
um what yeah never mind he's kidding
here's a little xqc update oh you guys
are interested I personally am enjoying
watching the yeah
the plane hit the side of the mountain
Okay so
xqc claims that
um he's reached out to practically
everyone
to ask for permission
but when Vince came out and said that's
not true he sent his fans on Twitter to
say oh this guy's harassing me and he's
lying to send his fans to harass him
okay but another person now has come out
and said
[Music]
um
he did not contact me either
uh let's take a look let's post on our
subreddit
this is by
the Asher show who we love
uh here's his video two years ago 15
minutes 27 seconds 1.4 million views xqc
almost got the same amount of view
and it's 60 Minutes long same thumbnail
in his dumb face
and then by the way is if Ms Kiff is
doing this too he needs to stop
also you know xqc is just the biggest
and he uploads that to YouTube I I
don't know what mizkiff does if he does
the same thing he got to stop that
it's up no matter who does it
yeah
the coming views xqc got though
you know
so I guess you know Asher show reach out
for that 10x
which by the way he refused to pay Vince
now that I don't understand the 1000 he
says that's what he said what he said
now 100 millionaire yeah who goes to
Vegas and happily wastes a million
dollars
who's gambling Again by the way yeah
that's what he's gone back to just being
a gambling streamer so oh that's cool
um he said unless you can prove damages
I'm only going to pay you the revenue at
earned that's not what he said here nope
sure isn't I don't know what he said and
like why are you being such a cheapo
dude
don't say it unless you mean it oh right
because he's a liar he doesn't he
doesn't care about anything
here he is uh
gambling on Kik again
which again is so funny because one of
his main defenses against me was you're
a liar because I haven't gambled on kick
and I said okay you're right apologies
was true at the time what I didn't get
there but I really wanted to ask him
which I didn't get a chance to was do
you plan on doing plan on it yeah right
but this was like two days later and he
is just
right back in it yeah
so what do they do what is this gambling
it's like a slot machine yeah
that's it that's it oh my God on love
love has watched them so he gave us an
Insight I guess it's just I mean there's
ups and downs I guess it's exciting I
don't know I mean look he's got 800 000
here and he spends fifteen hundred yeah
and I think the spins are even more
because he does he they buy into the
bonus directly or like the uh so so they
they spend like usually 15K for a roll
and they get guaranteed to come into the
bonus round
uh so they yeah it's such scumbag
like you're not he's not losing money
he's getting paid a gajillion dollars
and she's like a fun thing that you do
and you know you don't see the part
where like he's stealing from his
like friends and family he's selling
like his bed
what is that but if you're a gambling
addict you lose everything oh gotcha but
he's still he's crushing it man yeah you
know what I mean his life is great
you don't see the dark side
gambling yeah
um here he is playing oh dude he won 500
000 oh this was like his Second Spin
right I don't know if it was the second
brother yeah I saw a lot of big wins the
second he started like five minutes
after he started he won
a five hundred thousand dollars outside
how lucky just authenticate then steak
would never
stake the unregulated crypto Casino
based in a shack Unthinkable and uh
Carousel Curacao would never never never
um also
I think we saw this already but in case
we didn't
he was in Vegas with his boy Aiden Ross
also they're friends
yeah of course they are well they're
both doing the kid gambling so
they're you know thick as thieves
literally
here he is uh and here he is losing uh
1.1 million down
how do people respect this I mean like
the the vast majority of his audience
has got to be
life would be completely transformed
forever with 1.1 million dollars all
right does that bother you is it as a I
guess former or current audience member
of course a little bit yeah yeah like
how little he cares about money I mean
it's possible that people when people
look at this it's like they look at a
fantasy you know
well sure
so it's not they're not taking it
in a literal way I guess but
I just lost one million hahaha okay
whatever and then um
this was an interesting post oh he
called me out
yeah it was just we don't even have to
recap it we've gone over all the
but one thing missing is that post about
gambling from our subreddit I wanted to
read that uh that was debunked Ethan we
shouldn't read that but um yeah no
um but this is interesting this has
actually happened while we were live
um
breaking news
xuc's old gaming YouTube channel has
been changed into a Gamba channel to
promote his biggest wins from stake all
the original gaming videos have been
removed wow yeah sure exactly I'm sure
the 100 million dollar contract that you
signed was not related no way you didn't
have to do any of this stuff also the
problem with advertising gambling with
twitch streamers is that you know you
see them lose a lot so what you should
do what he's doing is to just cut out
all the highlights all the all the good
stuff of just all the money you win yeah
and so you can just Mainline that
you know what I mean look at this
awesome and these these apparently all
just happen he wants 670 450
000 500 000 and 500 000. that all just
happened yesterday guys that's two
million dollars
gambling on YouTube I think as long as
you don't link all right or you can
promote it a URL that you can post it I
think that's the the carve out although
to be fair I don't I've never watched
xqc gamble but I don't think he does
this stupid that train wreck tries
to do
right he's like no it's gambling and
you'll you'll use a chance you'll you're
gonna kill yourself if you watch this
there's like a measure there's like a
measurable amount of people that will
kill themselves right because from being
addicted
because some of you will die as a result
of watching this all right let's spin
uh train wreck at I mean he he kids
himself into thinking he goes you don't
gamble you will lose money it's like
whatever
dumbass okay well that's that's really
cool
nothing seems to affect him though uh uh
it seems like some people are getting
over his stuff but he's still getting 50
000 views of him just doing a slot
machine
you know writing stuff yeah he's he gets
Castle though on and just bounces back I
think most of his viewers don't have any
morals I don't really care yo train
wreck won 10 million dollars on wanted
the slot machine here he is reacting to
it so it's not even his content it's him
reacting the train winning
yeah go ahead
well you know and just like
go ahead gambling react content I'm just
I'm blown away that this is a thing like
as if the gambling content wasn't
brain dead enough we need excuse
me in the corner well you know why
because I know train probably posted
this on his xqc posted on his why
because steak is paying them to promote
the wins
yeah maybe maybe and then maybe we can
have uh Aiden Ross react to the xuc's
reaction of grain winning 10 million you
guys this is wild here it is
no way
oh my God oh my God no way no way no way
no no no
I got the full screen no way well it
took him so long
why is he being was he being a hater it
took him so long he just won 10 million
dude give it down to your homie dude
look how happy he is oh my God bad axes
too I got this oh
but we'll take it
that's that's minimum yeah home screen
we just asked for it we need to sound
bite that
okay but just
oh wait that's not a maximum
wow xqc that was a really good reaction
I understand why he posted that that was
definitely an xqc highlight can I hear
it again I just want to yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um train Rock do you think he's even
excited or is it just like an ax he
doesn't care he doesn't care no is it
all like he all he's a part owner of
steak now he's he's just and that's just
crazy oh no no
but those are the same people he's
literally in business with them now he's
in business with them yeah I go to three
I got the full screen
but we'll take it that's that's minimum
yeah not the full screen we just no we
got the full dude
who just asked for it and God answered
wait that's not a maximum
that's unlucky as that kind of
makes them all actually
that's unlucky as kind of makes him
mulled actually is this what I caught
the 10 million right yep
yeah so um you guys are interested in
watching him react to other people
winning
oh wait no this is xqc clips
wait now I'm what the is this why
is the view so low oh God he posts that
much
no it is he posted two minutes four
minutes five minutes seven minutes ten
minutes 15 minutes one hour
thank you
so uh congratulations to Trane
10 million dude he got all three
All Right Moving On
um
okay this is very good
now I saw this on Reddit
and Zach did some leg work
to try to figure out if this thing is
real look at this
uh what is West Virginia
correct uh yeah it is where's Virginia
we're back to West Virginia today
the fat people save the pedophiles
this was hanging in the police station
okay
what does the scroll say
and some call him Pig
what do you see here
I see a disturbing image
disturbing about a peace officer saving
the life of a child with CPR I don't
think you do CPR in yourself they are
kissing I think he's supposed to be on
the ground that's the explanation that
was uh offered for this yeah I mean
clearly it's supposed to be a
resuscitation but in the arms yeah it
looks like chest compressions no okay
you have to alternate he's taken
advantage of it yeah
potentially a deceased child
um so beyond the creepiness of this I
have a theory about this painting okay
it's very similar to a famous painting
by Peter Paul Rubens of Cronus devouring
his son I just linked it
oh and this is actually a depiction of a
tyrant preserving his power I don't know
wow wow you think there's some occult
chick going on I think it's a subtle a
cab to the creepiest oh the artist was
uh that would be so iconic it does two
things it one depicts the stadium is a
creepy little creep and two it
just shows him as a Tyrant
preserving star very interesting
interpretation that's actually very
interesting yeah that makes more sense
than someone remaining this in Earnest
yeah so but they put it on they put it
up in the PlayStation so let's back up
for a second
all I was able to find of this was a
handful of Reddit posts and in the
comments people saying it was in this
police station now I that I was
skeptical oh maybe it's not well it's
just like because you could just put
that picture from wherever and just say
why is this in the police department it
could be a troll however in several of
the threads there were replies that were
saying that identified the police
station yeah I've been there I've seen
it still isn't definitive proof this is
awful
[Music]
ha
let's start over Okay you think that's a
problem
prefer not to okay okay it's in West
Virginia the state of West Virginia yeah
yeah yeah so this
um specific location
um I gave a call and I said hey I'm an
art student at the University of West
Virginia
and I am doing my thesis on uh art in
the uh
you know Public Service uh buildings if
you will
and this woman she was she was nice I
said my Spiel and
she's like hold on one second
minute goes by and I get a voicemail
she transferred me to a voicemail
and that's all I got with it
unfortunately what my take from that was
that the fact that she didn't outright
deny it
makes me think that was right so
there's two two theories I would have is
one who's this dumbass like why
the you know well I don't give a
number two is people might have
before inquired
um so I don't know I feel like you
couldn't have been the first person
correct and so I think that was up
I think they did it man I I would agree
with that I think he res resuscitated a
child with his with tongue
I mean an apologies for that but that
you know and some call him Pig
right the artist is one of them
no I feel like this is uh
I feel like this is just like a a
painting that's made with that statement
and I feel like it's probably not in a
police station
that's my feeling well that was my
feeling as well but I was only after
seeing repeated mentions of uh because
again it wasn't just one thread it's
been posted to Reddit four or five
different times over the last several
years and again and in each one somebody
would crop up and be like I I've been to
this police station I've seen it wait
I'd love to see it wait we have a new
development holy yeah hold on this
is actually a reference to this yeah so
it's not a Kronos thing this is a real
thing
1971 police advert what some call him
Pig here's the cop uh resuscitating a
child with tongue while holding it what
is this demon oh this is real so
this helps the case of the validity of
the pain I guess it helps and Pace
significantly yeah dude 1971 was a crazy
year
wow what a fine in none of those threads
did I see anybody mention this that it
had history this is breaking this is
breaking this is an H3 podcast exclusive
I Googled some call him Pig and like
scroll down way down and it was on
Google Images huh yeah you can even see
it's some advertising company
there's others yeah it was like a whole
campaign yeah what the were they
thinking man I guess people didn't even
really think about like pedophiles back
then
they're just like no he's a pedophile
that's cool
they're like that's dope it's part of
their job man I don't think that's what
people think I see one some call him Pig
I call him officer and Sir welcome
Georgia police okay you know what it's
like a anti this is an anti police hate
uh campaign and they managed to make it
a cop
a child
all right my question is this
that's so that's so much crazier yeah
this was up in a PlayStation there's no
chance
[Music]
okay here's my question you got a cop
with a dead child he's making out with
here you got another cop with a passed
out child
here you got another cop Matt Gates why
are all these cops hanging out with
these all of these pastel kids because
they're pigs
[Music]
I'm calling Pig and they'd be right
a public service advertisement from
Hustler magazine
Hustler University Hustler magazine oh
so that's that's a troll then no yeah
yeah a public service advertisement from
Hustler oh Larry Flint Larry notoriously
would do trolling like the police
why would they put it on a stop sign
here it says Outdoor advertising company
of the Twin Cities Inc
on this one
we got a dick we gotta dig more we gotta
get to the bottom of the story this I'm
fascinated now here's another billboard
and some call him Pig hmm
Fraternal Order of the police so they
definitely paid for this Jersey City
Lodge four although this one he's not
kissing the child
simply holding it yeah all kinds of
versions of it like there's a bunch of
Google some calling Pig it's such a
crazy ad campaign it's like yeah yeah
well one officer saved the kid once
therefore
don't think about anything else just
don't worry about the other stuff
I think this is real I I don't know what
to say this I don't know that this one
was in Hustler and this one he's not
even kissing the kid
so this one seems somewhat serious
the fact that it says it's from Hustler
magazine leads me to think it's not I
mean
well did did have a problem with the
police I mean he was a First Amendment
Advocate
um
I don't know
you could by the way you can see an
officer's name on this
yo you can St you can see the name of
the pedo officer oh oh that's
interesting
why people be worrying about gold miners
instead of minors on an island somewhere
hmm
why people not worry about
the pigs making out without kids
and not the pigs eating our corn
you gotta have that song Maybe ready for
me Zach people are saying this is the
you send me the link that you because
you already scrolling so fast oh here it
is uh we are furiously thought checking
the story which is yeah okay constantly
developing directly above the Hustler
thing it says here it's being mocked by
Hustler
because it's dumb
yeah but so this look is a giant
billboard and like LA or New
York City or some major Metropolis area
this work concerned a billboard enormous
advertisement in the Minneapolis Police
Department had produced and put up so
they did this in various parts of
the city Jesus
they did this
the only European Observer pet Tana
underlined its contradiction in terms
and unintentional irony and
comprehensible to the Americans of the
Midwest the poster was paid for by the
police department to celebrate the
courage of their agent but faced with
the image of a policeman kissing a
little boy on their mouth I said it was
no surprise they were called pigs but I
was also the only one to have seen it as
a kiss and the others saw nothing funny
in it interesting this is a fascinating
story yeah
so yeah the police did this yeah
so it seems that
yeah they were getting mocked just
because people hate the police but I
guess the pedo thing wasn't really
observed by any but a European Observer
I guess I guess they're more used to uh
the
they've been around the church for
longer you know what I mean they know
they know what they see
the European's been around longer than
the Americans
that's a that's pedophilia no no no
that's called Sunday school boy I don't
know what y'all Europeans get up to but
that's just quietboard training show us
we put all our choir boys through
similar training experiences
us here's us more information about it
some call the him Pig we'll see the The
Source here
the American Catholic political and
cultural culture from a Catholic
perspective who who else would know
better yo this was posted in 2023 this
was post wait what the this was
posted today no wait no no no that's
just this is just the date
but thank you okay this came out in
2016. so not that long yeah there was
already the whole Scandal was pretty
much come to light let's hear what the
church had to say about this we seem to
be in danger of replaying the long hot
summer oh you see you're already getting
all steamy and hot
the long hot summer of the late 1960s
and early 1970s when the radical left
declared open Warfare on Cops the above
billboard was put up by Minneapolis
Police Department in 1971 showing an
officer giving mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation to a boy the poster went
viral Across the Nation
in the wake of the murder of five cops
in Dallas by a sniper Xavier Johnson
intent on killing as many white clubs
cops as he could
oh wasn't that guy of the cop
I think that guy was a cop if I remember
correctly what
I don't know
Micah Xavier Johnson killed five cops
cops are not above criticism and over
the years I've done a fair amount of
that however cops have a very tough job
most of them do that job as best as they
are capable fairly and with heroism
when they are called upon
to run towards danger you know they can
respond
just like what happened in uh
what was the school where they just
filled in the hallway his kids were
murdered Uvaldi just like what happened
in Uvalde baby that guy was uh
ex-military by the way he wasn't a cop
uh not from what I'm seeing so let's let
Jack Webb as Detective Joe Friday have
the last word okay let's hear what you
let's see I'm interested what's the
difference
you might as well know
she told me two days ago told you what
we broke up you know this is claimed
that shot like what the
oh oh it is seems like it oh
okay well the Catholic loves it
in 2016. of course they do
look at this some call him Pig I call
him sir
you best obey bar
now come here and give me a kiss
pretend like you passed out you know
what to ask no questions
um
that's right
okay that was a bit of a meme haul
interesting yeah
so I think in short I think we can
basically make an educated guess that
that painting is real I now feel much
more confident saying it's real yeah I
mean good theory cam I thought for a
minute that you were onto something and
it made more sense I mean it could still
be true for whoever originally designed
it in the 60s yeah
yeah well it makes more sense as a
parody than it does as a real statement
yeah
but
as far as we can tell that is real
as it gets man it's supposed to depict
safety and it is literally the most
dangerous painting I've ever seen
yeah I don't even think you could like
show that on TV
okay all right
that was interesting
Kid Rock You Remember Kid Rock he goes
Grant Grandpa's getting real fruits and
he shot a bunch of Bud Light
during the Dylan Mulvaney
he was like one of the main perpetrators
well gas okay send me the original video
it set this up properly
yeah
so
everybody was blowing up their beer that
they had already bought
reminded they were shooting it
they were
dumping it exploding it stabbing it
because Dylan Mulvaney drinks Bud Light
and we don't like that kind of stuff
grandpa is feeling a little is Dylan
Mulvaney drink Bud Light then it's like
I'm kissing her
I can't accept that so here's Kid Rock
making a sending a message to America no
to the world
here it is
go ahead Grandpa
[Music]
he's feeling a little frisky today
uh-oh let me uh say something to all you
and B
as clear and concise as possible
I don't like when Grandpa's feeling
frisky
so again
it's great either he went out and bought
these for this purpose right or he
bought them before
both are good purpose yeah I think he
bought it for this purpose which is
you know for sure pretty ironic but I
think he made his his message loud and
clear okay the message is that
I will never touch another Budweiser as
long as I live right because of them
promoting a trans woman right it's
despicable
how long ago was that video posted
I want to say like two or three months
ago oh is that it April okay a little
bit longer so anyway cut to uh Kid Rock
and join himself at the game with the
Bud Light concert actually concert he's
having the time of his life and he's
enjoying a nice cold Bud Light
but I thought you made yourself
perfectly clear now I'm confused what
was your message
I have I'm gonna have to re-analyze that
um
because I'm just more confused than ever
I thought I don't know his word I
thought you weren't gonna drink none of
that you telling me you was just doing
what I heard is virtue signaling kind of
thing
that you don't really care
one more time because again really
confusing
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
right let me uh say something to all you
and B
as clear and concise okay it's awesome
okay
are you shooting
Bud Light
huh badass but then he's drinking Bud
Light a few months later beta
and Anheuser-Busch have a terrific
day
maybe they made up
him and Anheuser-Busch they made up
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
I guess he was feeling a little frisky
on this day he's like I'm gonna
around and have a Bud Light that's clear
and concise as possible what a phony
what a phony like you don't even
give a like you don't even care
enough to not drink it for like a few
months
and here you are basically advocating
for violence against trans people and
you don't even care Kid Rock we drank
beer also your white trash in your music
sucks
maybe he changed his mind and now he's
he's down
yeah yeah oh maybe he's a trans yeah a
trans Ally I feel like there's a
statement he's holding it up probably
trans allies yeah he's facing the logo
to the camera I think honestly
shout out to trans Ally Kid Rock
maybe that's the vibe I think it's far
too
here he is from another angle actually
it's like an ad for Butler he's out
there like so
publicly it has to be uh he's holding it
over the edge high up in the heavens but
light man I mean you can read the words
and he's at a country show so I mean
dude he's talking right to the
people yeah I've changed wow
shout out trans Ally It's a soft it's a
softball
okay it's a soft launch yeah I'm glad
you did some work he did some
introspective some therapy education
probably spent some time with some trans
people better learn about their real
experience
coming out with a statement should we
make a post on Twitter just shout out to
trans Ally Kid Rock Let's do that
I love post the both images the first
one and this one
and you can do it from the podcast shout
out to trans ale like Kid Rock we
appreciate your support cheers my dude
cheers my dude love you
guys
looks like
love you we didn't blow those up
I was feeling too frisky today
I thought we blew all those up last time
you probably should have kept that to
yourself my guy so there it is Kid Rock
out there sticking to his goons brother
I'm Kid Rock I stick in my guns
oh God love sculpture yes let's take a
look oh my God yeah wait you ready
let's do it yeah yeah okay let's go
okay okay wait it's like we're at
the bottom of the show already I yeah
I feel bad that we didn't do it earlier
we could do it on Monday
well yeah it's up to you let me see what
Dan thinks we had a good old time I
think he's taking a dump
he ran off real quick and he's been gone
for a long time or he's eating the food
no I think
he's taking a thumb yeah he's in it I
just heard him come out
Dan's feeling a little frisky today
um Brittany here said show Ela the girl
going down the slide the one who fixed
her reflective
as a diaper
there was a fan who went down the slide
with a vest she was going very fast
she launched it yeah it makes sense yeah
it does it does nice problem mystery
solved should we do love sculptor
sculpture on Monday because we're almost
out of time Dan
oh sure I mean we could definitely do it
now we could definitely do it doesn't
take long all right let's do it like a
big segment let's do it all righty here
you want to see this
the people I want you to see this oh
let's take a look yeah it was really
good I was really happy with her work
it's on as to mimic what the cop was
wearing I don't think anyone realizes
the Trek it takes to get up to this
slide you need to go through all these
Horrors
round two the slide a little bit white
on the inside cause a little bit of
friction so it's a little wet so I
decided to put the vest on my butt like
a diaper oh my God right through there
and okay the sheet definitely confirms
the fabric here
the second one she goes even further
watch out how far she goes
[Music]
good
I'm really far
yeah so nice
once again a big thank you to yeah
um
benzo babe
benzo baby 22. all right love show us
what you got shout out all right should
we just jump straight and set it up a
bit should we show maybe
once there's a gallery in there for the
other ones refresh our memory oh perfect
so here on the H3 podcast we do somewhat
of a ink blot test for the crew members
uh but instead of you know dabbing the
ink and telling us what they see they do
a sculpture of my face
and the results are just so profound and
so insightful into their beings that
we basically I need to see what love
really thinks about me
so so so as you guys can see I mean
stare into the souls some of these are
deeply disturbing Zacks
was the most disturbing I was
surrendered speechless
this one was also terrible thank you
thank you this one's just Wally P
so the winner was Ian's here but okay so
love you've you've made your own
creation so go ahead please yeah so I
guess we can switch I took the same
inspiration okay uh as the other crew
members so I have not this is not now
eating this is old Ethan yeah yeah it's
okay yeah all right
we go
whoa oh he got a little hat on too wow I
didn't know that you can take the hat
off yeah I'm gonna reveal the hairline
here too wow gorgeous
all right can you turn it to the side
for me sure
is that a prosthetic nose I see dude the
neck area is crazy yeah also you got my
patchy up beard oh yeah it's a
little patchy just wow oh my God that's
quite good what do you think Ethan the
loops are pretty good show me the front
some good old lips
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah those kind of look like
me
capture something right show me the
other profile
or the other way yeah
[Music]
yeah the profile is not it's quite a
one-dimensional profile I think it's
good let me move over so and let me see
the back please sure you know I did not
spend too much time on the back here but
it's quite lots of hair I went with a
artistic uh choice to
uh don't not add like wool for the hair
because some did right
um so it's quite flat up here but of
course the hairline is still
[Music]
beautifully lined up here and here the
classic McDonald's M hairline as we're
all fallen in love with wow gorgeous
gorgeous
uh-huh
yeah do a little cinnamon
[Music]
I'm scared I'm gazing into the eyes and
I'm fee I'm trying to feel what emotion
it is you might as well see the eyes are
beautifully
um collared too they're actually Hazel
Hazel yeah I'm Amber Amber I'm Amber yes
Amber yeah
good work
you know it's not
some of these terrified me like I was
like this person's Disturbed or they
want me dead sure I'm not getting the
same
10.
interesting
I see the resemblance I think it's kind
of great it genuinely does look like me
beautiful oh well let's spray it
want to do a side view for the close-up
too I feel like it's the mouth and the
chin
dead ringer
nice
so honestly it's good yeah and I gotta
say I think you might actually not hate
me based on this oh yeah I don't know I
don't definitely not there's a there's a
scene there's a Serenity in it right
yeah there's
you know how long did it take well
that's a good question it took uh
probably total one and a half hour I'd
say Okay
um the longest time took to like put all
the clay on we did that yesterday and I
guess I spent 30 or 40 minutes painting
it today
um yeah it took a long time to blend the
colors too
yeah I think he did a great a fantastic
thank you yeah yeah it doesn't give me
existential dread so yeah right that's
good it was I I made the eyes way too
smaller first did give a little bit of a
creepy vibe to it I did make them a bit
bigger oh you you uh okay you redid it
well I just kind of made the pupils too
small it looked like you were staring
into my soul
mm-hmm all right very good here we go
thank you
he'll join the pantheon of
of Heroes yeah we have the
a little display Shelf with all the
heads thank you love very well done very
well done beautiful
it's really not easy
at three dimensional head
no I I mean listen I think everyone I'm
impressed with what yeah me too
accomplished
but what I mean like look at Zach's and
then like you understand how
how
I was literally speechless when this was
unveiled
truly uh
and like uh really a formative day for
me
there's no shot this is me and not Wally
P we did this one look at the reference
next to it I thought you did this one
yeah I just think I went too close to
the reference I just did the reference
actually because you're like a load
angle there
that'd be fun oh God because you're
gonna be really meaningful I just feel
like it seems fun to do do it that'd be
awesome
maybe I should do one about myself too
just keep it all going that'd be fun
yeah yeah that's a little portrait yeah
interesting
interesting let's get Shredder and
Alfredo do it too right that is so sweet
it's actually very therapeutic to do
very calming everybody a great time
that's what everybody says yeah
so where's the pizza cause yeah
it's on its way
ETA do they know that there's a pregnant
lady 30 minutes from the time I ordered
it so let me it's been way over 30
minutes no I agree it's been like
over an hour when they're close you know
how close my has like a priority option
there needs to be a pregnancy option
right so oh jonesing pregnant and hungry
maybe once
been exactly 30 minutes so they
should oh it's only been 30 minutes yeah
yeah be calling anytime
all right so let's let's move on here
you know what I was enjoying as we wait
for the pizza
I was really enjoying that country
singer I'd like to listen to some of his
other songs
that are partying actually I am curious
is it also like the same that's what I'm
wondering if it's also like I hate
people or was this one
one where he was fed lyrics and the
others are different let's look into it
so what's the name of his song that's
like number two let's see it's on the
chart I'm looking forward
I think can you also just check the
copyright before I throw it up that it
doesn't get clamped oh true and in the
meantime let's just enjoy the rich man
out here in Richmond
they found as
they stand outside the world will fit
office
like it's a food truck hey these fat
they ruin all goddamn beautiful country
so the number two one is called ain't
got a dollar and it was actually
published 11 months ago ain't got a
dollar
so this one is actually predates
the smash hit by quite a bit it now has
a lot of views okay hold on the other
one this one feels more authentic this
is a dude in the woods with a guitar
filming on like this one I feel bro this
is okay this yeah yeah this you can tell
this is like phone footage this is real
country folks it's a real why here
let's put on the lyrics
uh I see the lyrics are actually in the
description and got a dollar um although
I got CC sounds like a dollar in the
woods
I found the fat man in the woods working
all day he was hungry wouldn't feed him
pay so I can sit out here and
waste my life away this is the other one
I'm not playing it that's that oh gotcha
just get the fat part
did you did you check the copyright on
this I'm downloading it to re-upload it
and check I'll just I'll wait a sec his
voice is beautiful yeah I was listening
to it I shame
um but
it's beautiful there's a listen
beautiful voices are dime a dozen we're
in a country with 330 million people no
you're right about that you know
whoever's a successful musician is such
a crap shoot slash just about how
attractive you are most of the times
right definitely well thank God I look
like a supermodel then that's right yeah
brother
art Rob
all right um towering at six six one
four
thank you to whoever clap
all right as we wait for the uh Clan
[Music]
why is he worried about taxes it's his
tax rate he probably lives in a tax-free
State anyways right like literally why
are you crying about taxes bro do you
even make money
the fat are eating
Twinkies you know what I'll do is
this song's like super easy I'll just
re-record it so we can just have a bed
of it
check this out what does this make you
feel Ela
oh my God
that's like
oddly it works it's quite good
that's me and claymation you did good
love oh well thank you thank you very
good I used to do it when I was a kid I
got yeah yeah I worked with stuff and my
parents do it too
are we good on this Dan
uh
uh looks no immediate claim all right
just keep an eye on it
all right this is dollar in the wood no
ain't got a dollar
so this is a song I wrote uh it's based
off a true story it's called Uh ain't
got a dollar
[Music]
all right
well I ain't got a dollar but I don't
need to die
I got a little spot in the country where
I spent all of my time I got a sweet
little spot in the country with no
minorities that is literally like Simple
Man the Skynyrd song I think it's like
the same chords right I mean yeah it's
pretty standard right yeah
[Music]
skipping the course
I see why this one didn't go viral it's
just it doesn't have the oomph no
obesity jokes no obesity jokes they
don't they mention smoking weed in it
too yo that is not cool I hate this song
I can't see why they weren't promoting
this one
you know
nothing else crops growing in the ground
we'll have to pick some muscadines
muscadines
[Music]
okay okay boring found a dead dollar
founded that dollar
so there's no
um
I think so far it's supporting our
Theory
the Astro turfing yeah for sure
again why why didn't they share that one
so go back to my original question
what is the point of a industry plant or
astroturfing this is just to they're
trying to get like
again the problem is not the capitalists
the problem is the people on welfare the
people poorer than he is
no I'm just mean like the people behind
this it's just yeah that's just
propaganda because again it's like the
greatest trick but with somebody like
that girl from the podcast Bobby
what would be the reason
that I'm I'm still not on board with
that okay no one no that's not
propaganda they just want to make money
that's you know
I'm not on with the Bobby AstroTurf
although asterving is political usually
right
yeah I mean those are different concepts
although there's overlap but yeah
yeah I mean the greatest trick
that these genius diabolical uh
Republicans
get away with
is convincing a bunch of poor
country folk that
you know
it's Poor People's fault is welfare
people's fault it's gay trans people's
fault you know what I mean yeah
and like to support Donald Trump who
literally has a giant skyscraper in New
York City that he's their guy no no no
the guy who would never let anybody that
look like these yokies in one of his
golf clubs he would never let you shut
up you think these people would ever get
into Marvel you would technically be a
rich man north of Richmond and so this
is this is and all of them are all the
top Republicans are like straight Ivy
League
Mega privileged super wealthy
and and and they've and you know this is
brilliant propaganda for them to
convince
these types of people that
Ain't Us boy it's all the fat people and
twinkies and all that you know
all right
listen
I'm trying to stretch this out I just
want the pizza we can just drop it off
yeah it's almost five yeah I mean we're
well well it's like if we're just
sitting here
no I just I remember we're just here so
might as well entertain the people while
we're here you know I mean keep the keep
the people uh
keeping keeping it up but this is a
really cool oh I need this clap yeah
I found a keemstar in the woods
um
let's listen to another one I guess
he is playing a massive crowd five days
after he went viral let's see what this
looks like
y'all filled 25 acres with cars for my
first ever gig
I am so proud to be a part of this
movement yeah don't tell him if you ever
give any kind of lib take in any of your
songs that you'll be completely
discarded because these people actually
don't care about you at all
as an artist or a person
just as a piece of propaganda they love
him
why is my health care not social oh AB
they went on a ab's not here today I
forgot to explain that uh they went
they're visiting back home
their family's in town I knew it was
family something picked a terrible time
to come to LA
with a hurricane
for the first time like ever yeah
that's crazy climate change is kind of
fun all of a sudden okay get some nice
rain out here in the summer sure you
know what I mean
uh thanks to everyone who stayed after
for photo and to tell me your story it
means more than words can describe if
you couldn't make it rumble.com baby you
know he posted on Rumble why not
of course he's posting on rumble.com
yeah that's another one like why is he
already on Rumble does it make any sense
to be on a rumble as a small Creator no
it's like yeah
that's like posting like thank you to
the Daily Stormer yeah
because of the best
do you want to listen to more music from
him not really really
okay
that's a shame
uh we got a tick tock singer accuses his
target employees of being racist
Pantano update I think I talked about
that and see next Tuesday but Activision
bailed on the Fontana lawsuit because
they're we're wrong so wrong I
was not following that story
they used okay so Activision
used Anthony fantano's sound from Tick
Tock he has a viral sound where he goes
that's enough slices maybe you've heard
it no someone's cutting a pizza and he
goes that's enough okay and then they
used it to promote a video game
so like what's been happening exactly
the same okay and so fantastic yeah this
fresh pie save me a slice
that's good so this was a popular salad
yeah that's all right that's good okay
okay all right okay all right okay
that's good that's good it's it's enough
slices
so
he wrote them a letter like we did yeah
I was like yo you need to pay me what
the and
um
and response these maniacs
they're like we're suing you well okay
so the headline was that they were suing
but what they actually they filed
something to like force the judge to
um
make a early a pleading something I
don't know what it's called I forget
what it's called but they're like
fighting it trying to fight it
and all there's all these headlines
about Anthony fantanos being sued by
Activision and they were trying to paint
it like he's this greedy bad guy and
people were taking the bait I feel like
too really someone he had a lot of
support too though I don't know
it was it was really sneaky what they
did
but my take was like there's no
I think they were just trying to do some
PR
but uh they dropped it and I'm sure they
settled and I'm sure Anthony got paid
okay
so there's no word if you actually got
paid or not I mean if it's settled yeah
because he's not gonna drop it no that
kind of stuff is like NDA kind of yeah
could be I mean it's up to the parties
but probably yes
yeah I bet you he got like
I think in the letter he asked for a
hundred thousand
I don't remember
but because of the uh the coverage it
got I wouldn't be surprised if you got
like
50 000 or something from that
good for him yeah that's enough slices
activation be like that's enough slices
um
yo Alfredo is so soft man he's so cute
he's the best
absolutely the best yeah
oh this is fun people like when we do
this react to the sniperwolf verse oh
that's long though if you're well we
don't have to watch the whole thing a
few weeks oh this is a Jax film one I
was going to react to a Darman Sniper
Wolf one that's what I thought you were
talking about
so what are you talking about
this is Jack first uh sniperwolf update
video oh I see guys a few weeks ago I
made a video about YouTuber sniperwolf
and how she's profited off the works of
thousands of other creators by reacting
to them in the laziest way possible
and on my other channel judge of Jack's
films we've gone much much deeper into
just how women her commentary is no this
channel is doing super good horrible
that Twitter user let's go check out his
channel uh like his it's really
interesting
films wait hold the phone wait
that is so funny Papa said they're 10
minutes out
the driver had other orders to drop off
Papa get your together man other
orders wait you got pockets on Papa's in
the house you want to do the stuffed
crust yeah oh they do that I thought
that was a Pizza Hut welcome to Papa's
house my bad here here's uh
his parody Channel I mean that's just
five hours ago he's got he's
crazy yeah no it's it's doing quite well
look seven minutes no this is this is
the channel that's like dedicated to
this one are these not highlights from
his livestream no he does he does
produce his videos oh okay no I think I
think he does it live I think he reports
them live and then posts them to this
channel okay yeah well he does put a bit
of work in the editing yeah they're
edited like that
we got another epic Sniper Wolf reaction
can we talk about how awful this crop is
this is a terrible crop which I believe
is a square I believe that's a new spot
so we have bro and we have terrible crop
good cards
okay let's let's see let's see the
thoughts
oh I don't have caption all right so
sound effect people are saying double
free boot oh look at the overtime
that might as well be a viral hog oh my
God yeah so I mean he really hit
something so funny really hit on
something I I don't even know his main
Channel videos we're not getting these
this many views no yeah and posting
every day too yeah I was just gonna say
that good for him man yeah good for him
do me a favor pull this channel up on
socialblade
I'm curious what's his monthly views uh
on this channel Jack's films
oh he's live on Twitch right now let's
pull it up
let's let's see the man in action
5.3 million views
that's money
um can you yeah he's live right now
let's check in on Jack
and then I I guess I gotta I gotta get
off this okay here's the deal
it's very possible there was unnecessary
yelling
holy crap Peter I'm I'm really really
cool what's this Library yeah it's 5
500. 5 000. yeah let's go dude I'll let
you decide on Twitch that's pretty good
I will finish the clip and then I will
let you guys decide
oh my God if I get a bingo I'll like
I'll gift Subs
um
but hold on let's finish the tick tock
uh
Sniper Wolf Bingo that's so fun yeah all
right so
Bros you can play along to type uh
exclamation Bingo he should be selling
bingo card sheets
and now she's using their bathroom
oh Lord
oh my God stop saying chibi stop doing
that
stop
um
let's see oh my God sign that so please
wash your hands for at least 30 seconds
I actually want a snack this is okay she
does she'll like she just she already
say what's happening before we even
narrating the video is not commentary
does this all the time it's we're not
transformative it's very very weird so
it's not like a natural reaction
actually I wonder is there a cut all
right I gotta go I'm getting tired I
can't do it anymore guys I wanted to do
it but I can't do it all right the pizza
is about to arrive so and you know I'm
still reeling from that dream I'm still
recovering
nobody wanted to throw no sleep my no
sleep
so guys listen
with all the peace and love in the world
I thank you
for being here for watching for another
great week of shows what the pizza's
here I'll thank God thank you
there you go you made it let's have a
slice on camera at least for the folks
at home
I hope you guys have a great weekend if
you're in L.A
or SoCal
watch your ass because there's a storm
coming this weekend yeah for real I'll
be out on we'll be out on the sea whale
watching
I'll be like Lieutenant Dan at the top
of a mast
rain or shine rain or shine
let's check the weather forecast because
it like changes every hour
because they don't know if it's gonna
like hit La exactly or if he's going to
go west
right now it's looking like a direct hit
oh my god oh yeah
oh yeah it's a direct hit
what is it gonna be like I don't know
thank you so much what do we got here
something Maggie oh
was this uh
okay I can remove it holy yeah
oh Lord still hot wow
okay this I'm not gonna complain because
I like it thanks for watching everybody
this is a crazier Pizza combo than what
I get banana peppers
mushrooms
chicken
it's the spicy little
change
see y'all Monday you guys on Monday
[Music]